e
uh environment agriculture committee I
am really really pleased to see you all
here and I'm looking forward to a really
great um bium working with you
all
um this Mo the way uh today will work is
this morning we're going to spend some
time on um just procedure information
how the commit Works what what are the
kinds of um pieces of legislation that
will come before us um how I know that
we have a lot of new people here
freshmen and I want to welcome you and
congratulate you for winning your
elections um and so uh we will go over
procedures and policies and other
pertinent information that we as a
committee need to
know and I guess we can get started
started on that I don't know if my um
ranking chair would like to have a few
words with you um welcome everyone U I
think that
mic get back to used to that welcome
everyone um I'm looking forward to
working with everyone uh this term and
uh I think that probably what I I I I
believe that the what we're going to be
doing is going through the the committee
procedures and I'm uh happy to let uh
representative Aon take the lead on that
and I will probably chip in occasionally
if uh I want to emphasize something uh
but um I just want to um one thing I
want to emphasize at the outset is that
representative Aon and I really work
closely together on committee leadership
we are both really dedicated to the idea
that this is a nonpartisan committee and
uh that's a long-standing tradition
since well before I started in 200 13 uh
so um let's uh I hope we can continue in
that spirit thank you my vice chair
would you like to have a few
words thank you madam chair um I would
just like to reiterate uh some of what
representative Bixby uh had to say I've
been serving on this committee since
2016 um and it is truly a nonpartisan
committee um we work really hard
together to get out good
legislation and when we agree to
disagree it's
okay um and we will have some of those
and some of those things we will
absolutely 100% agree on or sometimes
we'll have bills that will work so that
we can all agree um and it's really been
a pleasure and
working on this committee for these past
years and I hope everyone else uh has a
wonderful experience this
session okay thank you um I'd like to
start out going around the room and um
introducing ourselves tell us a few uh
interesting details or non-interesting
details about uh your interest in
environment and Agriculture and um I'd
like to start with representative
barar good morning good morning thank
you so much it's a pleasure to be
joining you all um my name is Liz barbar
I'm from Hollis um we are a very strong
agricultural uh Town um our history is
Rich and deep in that soil um my
background is I've been in the food
industry um since my early 20s I've
worked in restaurants I've owned my own
business doing cooking demonstrations
around New Hampshire um Massachusetts
into Vermont um I uh run several
Facebook groups that are focused on
nutrition um and uh good practices
um with food and cooking
um and um I currently am also the editor
of a local newspaper that we just
started we're celebrating our first year
um and my focus in that platform has
really been to share um information
about our local farmers
homesteaders um and small egg producers
you know really try to bring back into
the focus of Hollis the importance of
our local Agriculture and um to the
history um so I'm really looking forward
to serving I am a home Gardener um have
been using my Gardens as um a platform
for my business as well so um I know I
have a lot to learn and I'm very excited
going forward with everything you have
to share thank you and welcome thank you
representative H Haskins good morning
good morning my name is Linda H Haskins
I represent the town of exitor
Rockingham 11 this is my second session
and tour on the environment and a
committee I've been an environmental
activist my whole adult life so I'm
really excited to be sitting next to a
chef because I've taken a greater
interest in cooking since I've been
retired and actually have time to do it
and I've fallen in love with the Lost
Kitchen in Freedom Main if you haven't
heard about it it's a phenomenon more on
that later thank you representative
Kenny welcome thank you um my name is
Kathy Kenny and I'm from Hudson um I
grew up on a farm and actually it was a
a mink Ranch uh too and um I've always
had an interest in farming um I did
manage a veterinary hospital for 21
years I do have um you know a i garden
and I have um laying hens and so I'm
very interested in um the environment um
I also have been on the aabon uh been a
member of aabon for a number of years um
and I helped the Christmas bird counts
um things like that anyway um I'm
excited to be back on this committee I
loved it my first uh term and I'm
looking forward to working with everyone
thank
you thank you you're welcome
representative
wheeler welcome thank you chair Ain uh
my name is representative Jonah Orion
wheeler I serve the towns of petero and
Sharon uh last year I served on criminal
justice and Public Safety and I'm happy
to be joining you folks on environment
and agriculture this term despite the
appointed representative gerana good
morning good morning thank you madam
chair uh my name is Nick terana I am a
second term uh legislator and second
term on this committee and very happy to
be back I don't have a background in uh
in these fields I'm a a professor of
history at Keen State College but in my
first term I became particularly uh
interested in solid waste issues um and
as uh as some of you are about to learn
very very quickly we do a lot of that
stuff on this committee we'll talk a lot
of trash for the next few months um and
uh so as you said um I'm very happy to
be back on the committee thank you
representative Bixby yes um
representative Peter Bixby I'm from do
and uh I was uh first elected in 2012
and uh I was really wanted to be on this
committee because I do a lot of
Homestead gardening and orcharding and
I'm a member of the main organic farmers
and gardeners Association and New
Hampshire on nor Northeast Northeast um
NOA on
Northeast organic farmers or Association
um
and unpacking all the one one sometimes
gets overwhelmed by unpacking all the
acronyms so um uh so I've been for quite
a while I've been um providing most of
the produce uh for my family from our
Gardens and Orchard uh and we have
laying hands on um nothing larger than
that because I'm not zoned for it um and
uh one of the things that uh kind of
surprised me when I was on the commit
when I joined the committee was that and
I was expecting to be mostly about
agriculture and some environmental stuff
and all of a sudden we were discussing
all of these animal cruelty
bills and that sort of says wow where
did this come from but uh so there there
will be topics that you might not
necessarily expect when you um uh when
you sign up for an Agriculture and
environment committee but there they are
and uh you'll learn about them very
quickly so uh uh I guess that's um there
we'll learn more about each other as we
go on but that's kind of the nutshell
thank you representative
King thank you madam chair my name is uh
Seth King this is my second term in the
legislature uh last term I was with uh
HHS HHS committee and um I'm really glad
to be with this committee this is my
first choice this term um I'm also an
amateur Homesteader and I live way up
North and um the landfill issue is very
close to my constituents so um for that
reason that's why I chose this committee
and I'm very glad to be here what town
uh Whitefield is where I'm from so yeah
so I'm representive Judy Aaron I
represent uh Sullivan County District 4
which is all the way on the other side
of the state and I represent Five Towns
aworth Goan langon lster and
Washington this will be my fourth
term I've always served on environment
and agriculture my first term was uh as
a member my second term was vice chair
and my third term was chair and here I
am again
and um uh I live in aworth I also have a
I I wanted to be on environment and
agriculture since the beginning because
I come from a very rural part of the
State uh we do have a lot of farmers and
um people who are engaged in Homestead
food
production um I have a uh dog two cats
and a flock of nine chickens so and I
also do a you know pretty large garden
uh during the gardening season so uh
that's where my interests lie and um I'm
glad to be back and be back as chair and
hopefully we can get some really good
work done together representative
ktoa thank you madam chair um Barbara
coma uh from Barnstead Sena Barnstead I
serve uh Barnstead in Alton this is my
fifth term and uh prior to that I was
involved with the ENA
committee uh for several years prior to
that um and I met representative Bixby
before that uh when we working on uh
some raw milk bills and things like that
um Barnet is a is a huge agricultural
Town um we're 46 square miles and we're
also the beginning of the Lakes Region
um
but I also have well my sons have a farm
um it started out as ours we were into
we did hydroponic uh gardening we did
about 5 Acres of
Hydroponics and uh it was quite an
experience my son has chosen not to do
Hydroponics he wants to grow in soil so
he's gone into specialty berries
specifically hasc caps and kiwi
berries um and and they take about three
uh to four years uh to really start
producing commercially but he spent
about five years getting this the land
ready for that so he is actually taking
over our farm but um and obviously uh
food
security uh for the State of New
Hampshire for the population is near and
dear to my heart uh as you'll learn we
can only feed about 6% of our population
with what we actually grow currently um
which is a scary thought when we think
about that our grocery stores on 18
wheelers thank
you representative grber good morning uh
thank you madam chair um I'm very
pleased to be here this this is my first
year I hope to make it maybe uh more
than one term uh I'm a retired professor
of Environmental Studies um before that
uh I worked in town management for 10
years and um I started as an
environmentalist in third grade when I
took a pledge to not be a litter
bug you got to be old remember that okay
um
I I've worked in solid waste over a
number of years besides teaching
Environmental Studies um including uh
working in the US and over in Eastern
Europe where there solid waste issues
were a disaster after they drove out the
Russians um and I'm very engaged and inv
involved in agriculture too at a local
level I came here in 1978 to Homestead
uh we've done sugaring um we have a
small Vineyard and a winery that we make
wine from and uh live in 20 acres in the
back Hills of alad so very pleased to be
here and I hope I could help it looks
like a a wonderful uh group thank you
representative Scully good
morning uh good morning all uh
representative Scully this is actually
my second term not consecutive I was up
here in 17 and 18 and I'm back again I
had HED to Ser in the security my first
go around it didn't work out that way um
I felt my background would be useful to
um the Hampshire having done hazardous
weight cleanups investigations and
cleanups for about 40 years so I'm happy
I'm here now because I think I can help
with um my experience and expertise in
terms of trying to craft legislation
that will um make the hampture better
for all of us I also think that um food
energy and probably our medicines are
hugely important that we're able to be
self-sufficient here in the United
States so agriculture is a very
important issue and I'd like to help
with anything we can do to um Foster uh
and grow agriculture here in New
Hampshire thank you thank you
representative Howard good morning
morning Madam chair nice to see you
again um I'm Molly Howard from Hillsboro
District 31 I live in um Hancock and I
also represent Greenfield this is my
second term and my second time on this
committee um and I will um agree with
the the people who have asserted so far
that it is a very bipartisan and I find
a very effective and um and productive
committee um so uh my background is I've
worked in the food industry off and on
my whole adult life I also have a small
farm of eight chickens and and large
garden PL plots but um that's my that's
the extent of my my uh agricultural
experience um yeah so I'm glad to be
back and look forward to working with
all of you
thank you and good morning
representative
Penza good morning um representative
Kelly Penza I'm straford District 19
that is uh Rochester Wards 1 two 3 4 and
six um this is my second term um so I I
didn't pick environment and agriculture
the first term and uh I was I was
complaining and uh but it's the best
Committee in the house so for everybody
here that's new um we're rock stars I
mean I I don't want to Pat myself on the
back but um we are and uh I do have to
say you know just the collaboration the
bipartisanship all of that um you know I
think we should mirror what goes on uh
you know in the 400 group so um I do
have a background in in water stuff so
um I'm glad that I came to the committee
with having that expertise I went to
water science school um I used to work
for a for a um a well driller in water
treatment company so I'm very familiar
with those spaces but just like my
friend over there uh representative
gerna um I do like to talk trash and I
he was going to take that from me I
wanted to do that so uh solid race has
become my thing and there's just um
we've just met a lot of great people and
uh we've got to get a lot of things done
uh this year we've got to make things go
all the way and kick the field goal for
some of our legislation so I'm really
excited to be here and working with all
of you thank you good morning
representative
siketus good morning is it on yes okay I
um I'm from Nashville award s um if
you're familiar with nashwa it is my
wward starts at um East Hollis Street
and it goes all the way down to the
state line um the reason that I'm saying
that is because
I don't know four years ago this is my
fifth term maybe four years ago we
started to get a lot of letters about
Forest
Lake and
um so I I drove and I have a spinal cord
injury high in my neck and um my husband
had recently died but I didn't think I
could make it but I drove all the way up
to Fourth Lake and it was frozen and it
was covered with snow and we had a
constituent meeting in the middle of
force Lake before the Committee hearing
and I'm rabid about Forest Lake and um
I've I've met the people up there I've
worked hard with them and um I'm glad
that you're here from Whitefield because
I love Whitefield and and I'm so glad
that I got my eyes on it and I'm
actually thrilled beyond belief that the
governor said in her inaugural address
that there was not going to be a
Lake we have a problem in New
Hampshire because we have lack
regulations environmental
regulations and so it's people's
business models to get trash from other
states and bring it here and um
that sends me around the bend it's not a
free enterprise thing as far as I'm
concerned and
so I just feel like the other thing that
bothers me a lot is creep creep of the
housing as more and more housing needs
to get built people are going to push
further and further and it's going to be
we're going to be uh Boston's Northern
suburbs and what's going to happen is
they're going to want to put limits on
Family Farms in terms of noise in terms
of a lot of things they're going to go
out there they're going to have a MC
Mansion built right next to a working
farm and then they're going to get upset
about the noise and so those are the
things I think that Co taught us that
the
um Supply chains are easily broken and
we need to get the Farms pumping out
food I believe firmly in farm to table
and in Homestead
um that people with homestead should be
able to with minimal regulation sell
their products so those are the things
that that
um that mean a lot to me by uh trade I I
I'm a registered nurse and from the time
I was six years old I wanted to to be a
burn nurse and I became a burn nurse and
in charge of the burn unit at the brigam
for many many many years and and then I
got my spinal cord injury and I can't
work
anymore so please don't call me
representative just call me
Catherine thank you representative I'm
sorry but but for me as chair I need to
do that for dorum thank you
all right um representative Freeman good
morning good morning thank you madam
chair and if you want to close those
doors you can full disclosure I have no
experience in agriculture or
Environmental Studies um I'm a 35-year
retired occupational therapist so I
don't know if that qualifies me for
anything however I did um uh this is my
first term as a representative in Tilton
Bel now District 8 but I am um a second
non-consecutive term representative
originally from Manchester um I grew up
right outside of Logan Airport if you
can't tell so I think that kind of
qualifies me for environmental things I
grew up there when the airport was
expanding and a lot of the environmental
groups came in and said no you have to
stop this so I saw a lot of things I saw
when the Jets took off or especially
when they landed they would um they
would dump their jet fuel into the
harbor um before they landed because
that was a safety protocol back back
then so I saw some environmental things
and I can appreciate anybody here who
has worked on those things Boston Harbor
is now very clean but I don't live there
anymore um in any event I am an I am a
blank slate and I can't wait to learn
about the things that you all have been
doing on this committee formerly I was
on the election law committee which was
a pretty heavy lift um so I'm looking
forward to working with all of you and F
and now living in Tilton I can see the
true Majesty of the state and why it's
important that we work on these issues
and keep New Hampshire pristine not only
environmentally but make sure that
people have the opportunity to earn a
living on this land so um thank you for
having me and again I'm I'm a blank
slate so you know throw it at me I'm
here we
will thank you representative Freeman
representative Miner good morning I'm
Larry Miner I represent Fremont uh Rocky
ham number seven and um I'm the building
inspector in town um my background is a
former
educator uh licensed a master
electrician and a contractor it goes on
forever the list is um pretty pretty
long so I won't blow you with that
anyways the reason I'm on this committee
is because we also have a farm we um
process and raise uh over a thousand
Birds a year not only for us but for
other people we're the only um we're the
only Farm in Southern New Hampshire that
does process birds for other people uh
we have a great following uh we sell to
not only restaurants but out of our
store on our property and also at
farmers markets um there's a lot of
regulations I think that need to be
changed um things that hinder uh farms
in New Hampshire and it's certainly um
it's certainly achievable and I think
this community can do
it thank you thank you so much we have
got such a wealth of experience and
background and varied interests on this
committee and I'm even more excited now
to be able to
jump into all the bills that we have
coming to us so far I have seen we have
bills it's up to 25 now okay well who's
counting right um we have uh let's see
there'll be Animal Welfare bills
there'll be uh landfill bills there'll
be a policy bills um cat and dog bills
all kinds of things coming our way in
any case um I'm going to go start
through I did send around um a copy of
uh sort of a
committee orientation handout booklet
you can feel free to keep it as
reference feel free to toss it in the
trash uh whatever you
like and and the recycling bin yes um I
did send it to you electronically as
well in any case in general we will be
meeting on Tuesdays and I know that
there are members of this Comm committee
who serve on other committees thank you
very much for your your your uh Service
uh we uh would be uh meeting on Tuesdays
uh start time normally around 10 o'clock
um and I for our hearings um you know
usually we go till 4:
4:30ish depending on how it goes um and
uh if there's any changes to this um you
know what we're going to be doing I will
let the committee know via email if you
have also any time where you need to
take off um you would please let me
know or your ranking member from the
other side um so we we recognize that
you know we're all volunteers and some
of us maybe even have work other jobs
and whatnot um but if you cannot uh
attend in person um please let me know
especially when we are doing exec
sessions I will need to know whether uh
we would have to get substitutes for
you
um sure go jump in so uh in terms of
getting substitutes for exec sessions
that is something that is done on a
partisan basis so uh if you're a
republican then that needs to go to to U
representative Aaron and she would make
that request of the speaker's office if
that if you're a Democrat they would
that request you'd uh send that to me
and to our office staff uh in the
Democratic office and they need the and
then the Democratic office needs to make
the request uh for substitutes for for
the
Democrats thank
you uh house rule 102 excessive AB
absences each committee chairman May
request the speaker to remove from
committee membership any member of the
committee whose absences from committee
meetings are judge to be excessive in
number um so if if you are finding that
this is not going to work out for you
please let me know and we'll make um
adjustments uh email communication for
legislative business um you may utilize
the legislative email system now as I
understand pretty soon we are going to
be getting new email um emails instead
of using the leg do state. n. us I think
we're going to an nh.gov
and um speaker's office and our are will
let us know when that's going to happen
when the switch over I know that there
are uh some members of the House who are
testing that on a beta beta situation
right now um but for the
meantime we do have the house
environment and agriculture committee
email so I will will be sending out
corresponden uh using that
email uh to let you know about committee
stuff
um please know that any
um we we ask you to use the same email
for notifications from this committee
that you supplied to the house Kirk uh
clerk for all legislative activity and
also remember that any email account
that you use for legislative activity
will be subject to the right to all laws
so uh if you're going to be using your
personal email versus um say you know
the state the the legislative email um
you might want to be aware of
that dress in Quorum we ask you for this
committee um to dress
professionally um we will be we are live
streamed um so
remember that these meetings are
recorded and live streamed to the public
and you may be on camera we ask you too
to turn off your microphone when you are
not
speaking uh food food coffee uh and
lunch
breaks we ask just also for decorum uh
during our public hearings and also as
we are being live streamed and people
are viewing you remotely we do not want
to have food or drinks other than water
uh on the tables
here and
um if you we so we don't want to have
like you know food laying around or
whatever and also if if you have some
sort of medical reason why you might
need to have something to eat um we
recommend that you the members step out
into the hallway or out of remote View
and eat or drink what's necessary and
also try to plan food schedules around
the committe committee breaks we will be
breaking for lunch normally when we have
1:00 use of electronic devices you may
use electronic devices as needed to
perform necessary committee work I know
some committees forbid people from
having laptops or Chromebooks or
whatever on the table
I don't really care I just want you to
make sure that when somebody is
testifying that you're not on your phone
texting somebody you're not on your
laptop looking up you know something on
Amazon that you please give the people
who are testifying who have given of
their day uh your full attention and I
think this committee is also pretty well
known uh for the attention that we do
provide to the people who come and
testify before for us so please please
make sure that you are affording them
the attention and the courtesy that you
would expect for yourself when you go to
testify in other committees
representative gerana thank you madam I
just want to Second something the chair
just said that we have people come up to
us after testifying I've seen it
countless times and they're just in awe
of how much respect they got from the
committee and say this is so different
from testifying in front of other
committees and so so um you know I think
that's a great culture that's been
created in this committee and and people
will will let you know how much they
absolutely um
okay we have in our committee room which
is on on the other side you go out the
door and you hang a left here is a
committee room and that's has uh
committee room drawers there's a file
cabinets with drawers in it you will at
some point all be getting um a bill
folder once they get all the bills that
are coming to our committee photocopied
each one of us will get um a bill file
and you as far as I'm concerned you can
keep that bill file here it's supposed
to stay here but some of us have binders
and I keep my files of my uh of of the
legislation
the bills in in my binder I take it home
with me um that's up to you I I don't
really mind it if you keep it here you
don't keep it here we're all adults and
responsible and I think we can figure
that out um emergency procedures for
this committee
room um sure represent VI so so the
folder that um that the bills come in
needs to stay it should actually stay at
your desk when you finish it when you
finish because that that gets that
folder gets reused by a committee
assistant to pass to provide more bills
each week until we're done with them um
so uh you can take the bills out put
them in your drawer leave the folder at
your desk so that it can be collected by
the committee assistant and um and that
that's sort of the way it operates okay
thank
you so we have emergency procedures for
this committee room um and um if there's
any kind of fire alarm or anything we're
going to hear some sort of uh audible
alarm and I would announce an emergency
may exist and that we would have to exit
the building uh when we exit the
building we would use the West staircase
and go to Green Street which is out that
way um they don't want us in the lob
garage uh under no circumstances during
an emergency would we use the elevators
um there is the um the stairwell down
that way down the hall there if we are
to shelter in place we would go to room
307 or 207 if we are downstairs those
are designated waiting areas to wait for
assistance for those who can't exit the
building um and protective services
would be here to advise where to go uh
collection Point members are to evacuate
to a determined place where the chair
can take a head count and ensure all
members have exited the building and I
would suggest probably at the corner up
here by where they're doing construction
on um the new garage that we would
gather at that at that
place um for building re-entry access to
the building would be authorized by the
conquered fire department personnel and
communicated to Protective
Services in case of a medical e
emergency we would call
911 um which internally would be
9911 and uh we would have to uh then
describe what happened the victim's name
and condition please nobody have a heart
attack thank you I'd appreciate it um
AED devices are located in the L Lobby
downstairs uh we have procedures to call
27122 so protective services is a aware
of the situation U we would not move the
victim but clear the area around the
victim and I I would suggest you read
over these um procedures the emergency
procedures so that if God forbid
anything would happen that we are kind
of clear on what we're supposed to where
we're supposed to go what we're supposed
to
do
um if we had any kind of disturbance
which we really haven't had um in our in
our hearing
um we do have um a member of the
committee designated to contact
protective services so that they would
be able to come up and take charge of
that um our sergeant of arms here for
this committee will be representative
Miner since he's sitting next to the
door so he would be the one to in an
emergency uh contact Protective Services
or or at least let the committee
administrator know uh whether that we
needed some sort of
assistance we have um a list here of
General Court Protective Services Unit
phone numbers uh emergency after hours
main number and a nurse's
number any questions on
that thank you okay again U like I said
we have that n seat for the security
notification fire alarm exits um we have
on the on the bulletin board uh you
might want to take a moment to take a
look at
it as I understand it's supposed to be
up there um a chart is on the wall of
the committee room of where we're
supposed to go I don't know if I see
that though so I'll have to ask the
committee
assistant so environment agriculture
what are we doing here um according to
rule
31g it shall be the duty of the
committee on environment and agriculture
to cons consider all matters concerning
Agricultural and farm problems of the
state physical land use including
current use the various agricultural
organizations the protection of state's
environment from forms of pollution
other than air or water which is
designated to another committee we deal
with waste management issues and such
other matters as may be referred to
it again I want to reiterate environment
agriculture has always been run as a
nonpartisan committee and we expect it
to remain that way so we hope that you
will keep your R&D at the door and when
you come in here we're all going to work
together to solve problems for the State
of New Hampshire I think it's really
important um I know that we we will have
philosophical differences on how to
solve problems and that's okay we can
agree to disagree and be um agreeable
about that um
worked so far and I hope it will
continue to work
um for this bium the size of our
committee is 16 members we did have
20 um and the balance of uh of course I
just spoke about nonpartisanship but it
is nine Republicans and seven
Democrats um but we will we will work
together on these issues
um anybody have questions about that
because I find that's very very
important representative minor actually
I'm sorry this may not be relevant but I
just wondering where is the mileage
kiosk in these buildings oh yeah uh
mileage kiosk in the lob is downstairs
in there's one on each side and it's by
if you go by the um security desk y
there's
one on one side side of the building by
the women's bathroom and one on the
yeah okay um I have laid out and worked
with uh
representative Bixby on our committee
seating we are sitting a mixed seating
which I'm I know other committees sit
Democrats on one side or holigans on the
other we decided we didn't want to do
that um and if anyone is unhappy with
their seat or wants to change please let
me know
no represent also like to uh note that
we also when we designed the seating we
also tried to pair newer members with
older members so that um so that you
should have someone who is more
you so you know they can lean over and
say well what was that motion what does
that mean representative Scully uh
question Madam chair regarding the issue
of pollution um are are we do we deal
with soil pollution yes okay I it's kind
of weird because sometimes soil
pollution can also result in water
pollution so have you dealt with issues
and how does that handle yes um well you
know uh
the the the what the committee on uh
resources they do um soil pollution as
well and water runoff so sometimes um
depending on what the speaker deci
decides we may get bills that they might
hear or they might get bills we might
hear but there's sort of a gray area in
there I don't know representative K you
look like you want to say something
thank you madam chair um and a lot of
times some of those issues come down to
uh like one of the issues had to deal
with fertilizer run off into water so
because fertilizer is a a a what we are
tasked with it's our purview here so it
depends on the topic in the actual bill
whether it comes to our committee or
another
committee okay represent vix so uh there
are um there are a couple of levels of
that one is that uh the the committee
the the way that bills get assigned to
the Committees is uh in in Practical
terms is done by the speaker's office
and uh they may choose to assign
something to our committee or to another
committee that doesn't seem to
necessarily make sense at first glance
and there are two possible answers to
that one is that they have a huge number
of bills to assign and sometimes they
make mistakes and if that happens we try
to catch it fairly early for instance
last term there was a bill that had to
do with solid waste permitting in
municipalities but it had to do with
Municipal fees and I noticed this and I
uh said to repes representative eron you
need to talk with Municipal and County
and get this vacated because this is not
ours uh on the other hand sometimes
there are gray areas in terms of where
you know where it go where it fits in
terms of one committee's purview or
another and there's also uh they're also
matters of which parts of Statute are
being changed so the parts of stat
statute that have to do with the
Department of Agriculture and with solid
waste and dees are really our purview uh
there was a bill that we was initially
came to our committee last term and uh
we wanted to amend it in order to change
it to the way that something was being
sold as opposed to the way it was being
disposed and we learned from the clerk
that uh well actually because it's
changing something in the in the in the
commer statutes we couldn't me we
couldn't do the amendment on that bill
uh so there are all sorts of things that
are you know eventually you learn about
these things but um but the short the
short thing is that we mostly get things
that are uh farming Solid Waste animals
and uh and food protection yep so our
typical Bill topics will be solid waste
which includes recycling landfills
product of stewardship
um a policy support and promotion
Federal food safety modernization act
Farm stands and Homestead food
operations
pesticides Animal Welfare both farm and
household and current use
issues early bills um I don't know which
of our 25 bills yet are called early
bills I will find that out later today
and so those bills need to be addressed
expeditiously because because they need
to go to another committee such as
Finance if there's a um a financial
implication or it may be you know we
deal with one bill that has to do with
an animal thing but it's also might go
to a fishing game after us I don't know
but anyway the early bills get priority
treatment in order to have them heard
and exact quickly so they can move on we
have in our
committee right now six
subcommittees and um a subcommittee is a
subset of our larger
committee
um when we have a bill that maybe needs
a little bit of extra work or uh some
further discussion uh subcommittees
those bills would be referred to the
subcommittee and subcommittees will
report back to our
committee um which will tell us what
they've found out or what they've
decided about that particular bill to
help us uh get through our our
work um each subcommittee will have a
designated chair so I have a a signup
sheet for the six subcommittees that we
have here um this we had eight people on
a subcommittee last time and uh
representative Bixby and I have decided
to pair that down down to five people
would be three Dem uh three Republicans
two Democrats on each one and so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to send
this paper around if you have a
subcommittee that you're interested in
serving on please write your name down
and uh representative Bixby and I will
then later go through and assign people
to those committees the
subcommittees yes representative Miner
uh with these subcommittees will it
involve more time uh being here in in
the uh uh legislative building yes so
normally what what we've done in the
past is schedule the the person who was
doing who's chair of the subcommittee
would um schedule the subcommittee
probably prior to a committee meeting
hearing committee hearings or uh on
another day specific that all five
members can attend so I just want to be
clear are are you saying that um that
subcommittee meeting may not be on on a
Tuesday it may be on a different day
correct it depends on the chair and the
committee members if they can decide on
a meeting on another day specific but
those committee subcommittee meetings
are noticed in the house calendar and
they are treated as a regular committee
meeting would be treated they're live
streamed they're uh people somebody
takes notes and um and you guys work on
particular piece of legislation okay
I'll have to I'll have to um speak to
you more about this and sure thank you
sure representative Bixby yeah so we do
make an effort to uh arrange it so that
the subcommittee is can meet on a
Tuesday if depend it depends on how full
our schedule is but we try to make it
possible to we try we we we try to to
minimize the number of days people need
to come in right but we also have to
take keep in mind the the
full the full schedule and the and the
and the
um and the deadlines sure I understand
that but given my circumstances I mean
two days would be about the the most I
could be here so we're going to have to
see if we can get creative with this
right okay yep thank you anyone else any
questions about
that um Madam chair so there are two um
areas where I feel like would I have
both interest in some expertise I are
you asking people to sign up for as many
as they think they're interested in and
you pick just pick one or two one or two
yep thank
you
okay um I also want to make it clear
that it's not our job as a committee nor
is it the job of the
subcommittees to fix a bad Bill we get a
bill that comes to us that's really not
complete um um there's a whole lot of
moving parts and it's complicated and
the way it's written is just not you
know kind of a mess it's not really our
job to fix
it um there are bills that may come to
us that might you know have some extra
questions that we want to get answered
that might need a little bit of um
tweaking here and there but a complete
overhaul of any kind of Bill that comes
to us that's not really something that I
think we want to get involved in um we
want to rely on the uh sponsor of the
bill to really come with us come to us
with a bill that's uh you know
substantial and makes sense and works
and that we can
consider represent Bixby yeah so that
being said uh what often drives our
decision to amend a bill or not amend a
bill is how important we think the
overriding issue is so last term we had
a bill on phosphate fertilizer and the
concept of the bill made a lot of sense
the way that it had been drafted had a
lot of problems so uh I took it on
myself and we decided as a committee
that it really made this is a really
important issue because cyanobacteria
blooms are you know getting out of hand
in the state and limiting phos is a huge
way to help mitigate that
so uh I I took it on myself to do a lot
of leg work for doing the amendment on
it and brought it to the subcommittee
and got more polishing on it and we
managed to get that F through uh it
passed you our committee unanimously
passed the house unanimously passed the
Senate
unanimously we had a little bit of an
issue with the governor but we uh both
the house the Senate uh made a very
large uh effort to make sure that it
that vetto got overridden and now it is
uh in and that was in law um on the
other hand there are other bills that
are just there might be some issue that
is real behind it but the approach that
is suggested is just completely
inappropriate and in those cases we are
likely more likely to say um back to the
drawing for next
year quite right representative
ger represent last point we did a couple
of bills last time where the the
approach was just not workable it just
not realistic but there was an
thats discuss a letter from thee to our
congal delation um so sometimes we're
able to ways talking commission or issu
or like
that without spending more time than we
the sounds like a water fountain going
on here thank you representative
Penza it was something something with my
mic sorry oh was it the mic yeah it was
sounding it up worked so it Wasing on
the bill and the represent came
introduced the bill and immediately said
there's just a couple little problems
with the bill and
you know the Bill's already on board
with the Senate U the senator was there
and brought the amendment and so instead
of having that Amendment have to get so
the bill goes through the house go
through the committee and then goes
through the house and then has to go to
Senate and then get Amendment there he
wanted to see if the committee he
brought the amendment forward would take
that amendment in so I'm hoping that if
there's you know collaboration on the
other side which we need you know we
need them to to push things through May
if there's any issues with any of the
bills that are coming forward to our
committee that we could have that
collaboration with Senator as well they
inherent so yeah and I just want to make
it clear too that when any bill goes to
a committee is your sponsor or
co-sponsor sponsor comes and introduces
the bill to the committee it is then the
committee's bill it is no longer the
sponsor's bill so but the sponsor can
come and say look at you know I've got
an amendment in hand because I saw that
there was this problem and we can
consider that Amendment um so there's
that representative kamat thank you
madam chair um and the other thing is is
that this committee does really well is
if we find that not only the issue is
very important we can retain the bill
and work on
mine uh so thank you madam chair um I
just wanted to say that if there's a
topic that's very important to us but
say the bill isn't ready for prime time
but we feel as a committee in the first
year we can retain that bill and then
work on it over a course of a few months
um so that we can uh come up with with
better language um and I know that a lot
of committees when they you know I've
heard that when they retain a bill or
something we actually work on all bills
we retain we don't retain bills if we're
not going to work on them we delve into
the subjects um we do deep Dives in this
committee which I think is extremely
important for everyone to understand
um we take our our jobs uh seriously and
retaining a bill is also an option
thank you madam chair thank
you okay anybody else have anything to
add any of our veterans NOP okay um so I
just want to also go over we do have
assigned to our committee a committee
researcher her name is Christy a freser
she takes the place of Kristen Grant who
was our committee researcher last year
um and they have
help they help provide information to
help our committee members do our job um
they also assist the committee chair the
clerk subcommittee chairs and they're
just technical
helpers um the research staff work with
the committee chairs and vice chairs to
ensure that we get information that we
need so if you have you want to get more
information about
I don't know certain use of rodenticides
or or uh a certain technology that's
being used um you can ask me to ask the
committee researcher to do some research
for you and I'd be happy to do that um
but all requests would have to come
through the chair it's not like you can
go to Christie yourself as a member and
say hey can you do this research for me
that way cuts down any possibility of um
say representative sofikitis and
representative Kenny asking for the same
information um independently and not
knowing we don't we don't want to have
duplicate work being done
[Music]
um the committee researchers work very
closely with our subcommittees they help
with organizational issues they help in
scheduling meetings um so they're
they're here to help us also with the
technical issues of uh gathering
information and and organizing that
information so I have in in your packet
here uh Christie's uh email and contact
number also we have the house committee
assistant which is the lovely Jamie
Wyman in the room next door she has been
wonderful um they provide a lot of range
of services to our members here um they
are both of
these uh folks who work for us are
nonpartisan um and must all of
everything is directly related to the
work that we do in this committee so if
you're on another committee and you need
help with something you have to go to
your own committee researcher or
committee assistant for that um Jamie
provides us with clerical administrative
support she helps me do the schedule
um she will type minutes and committee
reports and
forms um she answers whatever telephone
uh uh inquiries that come to her office
to let me know about them she does a
whole bunch of different things she will
not get you coffee she will not run
errands she will not make copies for you
um so just so that we're clear on
that okay yes sir represent Bixby one
additional note about our committee
assistant and our committee uh
researcher they are the committee
assistant and researcher for four for
four other committees so uh for for our
committee and three other committees so
um they everything that they basically
work with the committee leadership and
um and uh so when you're uh you so uh
take the lead from Judy and from
Andes contact that you have with the
assistant I you could say hi and be
friendly and all that sort of things but
in terms of asking for any sort of work
that should come through the chair the
committee
leadership
this okay I think there's a problem in
the system
yeah all right but we'll move along
that's okay um regarding our public
hearings um our public hearings are open
to the public and members of the public
agency heads and other representatives
from organizations to come to test
testify on the bills being heard it is
not necessary to have a committee Quorum
as a quorum is only needed for any
deliberation and official action so we
need a quorum if we're going to vote on
anything or exec on any
decorum treat everyone as you would like
to be treated um we want to make sure
that we give people the respect um and
courtesy that we would like to have have
for
ourselves um for members of the
committee uh we ask that you remove any
buttons or stickers that show any kind
of advocacy for or against any
particular topic that comes before us we
want to address committee members as
representative so and so um just to be
more
uh professional thank you
any questions that get information from
the person testifying ask questions
first of all this is really really
important in so far as you know people
come here they give up time from their
work they give up time from their day uh
they may travel a very long distance to
come and speak to us and testify before
this
committee I want to make sure that we
afford them every courtesy you might not
agree with what they
say um
but we want to make sure that um we
don't argue or debate with anyone
testifying we want to be respectful and
treat everybody again as you would like
to be
treated we ask that you don't ask
leading
questions avoid sharing your knowledge
on the subject or your opinion this is
the time for the public to tell us what
they think
we are here to listen and gather
information and all questions will come
through me so if representative Kenny
has a question um she would raise her
hand I would say representative Kenny
and then you would uh she would direct
her question to the person
testifying uh sure represent ktoa
thank you madam chair uh the other thing
too is
that um the chair gets to everyone
sometimes she doesn't see your hand but
uh there's myself and the clerk will
always be looking to see if someone has
her hand raised so um wait for her to
recognize you if you ask a question and
you have another question you have to
ask the chair if you can do a follow-up
you just don't get to do a free-for-all
for questions every question goes
through the
chair thank you yeah we we want to try
and keep it as uh organized as we can
otherwise everybody's talking over each
other and that's not good representative
King thank you madam this one's not
working well well
um thank you madam chair um I'm assuming
it's the same in this committee as it
was in my last committee that if you
need to get up and use the restroom or
walk away at any time you're not
obligated to stay stuck in your seat you
can just get up and go out um people
often do that if they have uh another
bill they want to testify on in a
different committee or if they want to
speak with somebody who just testified
they want to have a talk outside in the
in the room you're not not glued to your
seat
so yes but I would that being said I
would like to make sure that um you are
not getting up moving around coming to
your seat leaving your seat in the
middle of somebody testifying because it
is rude and um if you would wait until
the person has finished
testifying uh to get up and leave for
whatever reason then that's perfectly
fine uh thank you Ma thank you madam
chair uh the other thing is is if you do
get up and you leave your seat you need
to wait at the end of the aisle until
the chair recognizes you to come back to
your seat um that way if we're in the
middle of a conversation there's no
disruptions for anybody the other thing
is is that nobody from the audience can
go past these desks um and come behind
our
Bixby oh dear all right I'm gonna just
try to speak loudly okay all right so uh
one other thing in terms of and I think
that I I agree entirely with everything
that representative Aaron said in terms
of uh decorum and uh politeness with
people who are testifying and I just
like to amplify that one of the things
that is part of that is never suggesting
that someone who is testifying has some
sort of a particular ulterior motive uh
we uh we want to be dealing with facts
here we don't try to guess people's
motives and another thing that can
happen is if someone who is testifying
is suggesting that there is an
alternative motive to someone some other
speaker or some other side then uh the
chair will uh gavel that and say that is
not appropriate so uh we're trying to
really get the facts out we are uh this
is not about uh individual people this
is not about personalities this is about
what facts we need to deal with in order
to make a good uh decision
any
ger no oh my goodness all right I just
want to use myself as an example of of
how not to behave uh and and that
representative chair Aon brought up the
point about especially with members of
the public importance of the Forum but
also with some of our colleagues who
will testify we had a bill uh last
session where you know of our colleagues
was was presenting in a bill and was
making a number of statements that were
simply factually inaccurate um um and I
was part of the problem with the bill
and I admit I kind of you know got into
that argumentative mode with my
questions um and Not only was it not
helpful for the bill but it's also as
we've talked about how to reduce the
amount of time we spend on bills that
are nowhere near ready for prime time
that's one of the ways we make more
efficient use of our time it's by not
asking questions that don't need to be
asked but I I know I was guilty of that
and it may be a Temptation at times but
it's important to resist representative
kto then Penza thank you madam chair um
and I'd like to follow up uh with uh
represent bxby and represent Jama and I
know that sometimes it's easy that we
can get
confrontational um it you know and we
have to do that the time to discuss the
bill and what has been said is in exec
session we will have the opportunity to
discuss everybody that testified in all
testimony and we can go through it and
dissect it when we're executing a bill
or if that bill has been referred at to
a subcommittee um so there is a chance
to go through everything and uh really
have the committee work it all out if
there's any questions represent
Penza no
I guess mine is the only one huh this
one work no oh mine works you
mine I don't have any problems speaking
loudly um I agree with all of the points
um except for one piece like if you have
someone that is truly testifying that is
giving factually incorrect information
you can you can you can question them on
that if you know what the truth is it's
not that like we're not going to just
let blanket whatever happened I mean
that's that's our job um I do believe if
it's a bogus bill and I think this is
the point of where we all know what
happened with the tabling right we we
all heard all the backlash for that um
if we know it's a bogus bill that's you
know the way to get through it real
quickly is not to egg them on like you
know what Nick is say so
just let it let it go and then you know
we don't even have to any question we
know it's is something that's gonna
quickly get it anyway
so represent Bixby uh two points um one
just adding on to what what
representative kis said about executive
session we often will also have a work
session on bills and that is where we
sort of have an initial discussion with
the amongst the committee members about
what should happen with the bill and are
there things we need to do to improve it
uh the other thing is that I would um
respectively disagree with uh
representative Penza about uh
challenging someone who is saying
something that is uh that is not factual
you can ask a clarifying question to say
just to make sure that they're you know
that they what they're saying is what
they intend to say or if they they might
adjust it if they realize oh I said that
wrong or you might ask them or you might
ask them where did you get that
information
if someone is insisting on something
that you are fairly sure is not factual
you're not going to get to change that
they're not going to change it so
another approach is when someone else is
testifying you might ask the same
question to get second appendant yeah
okay
um so uh when somebody is uh coming to
testify we will get pink cards uh and
have them call them up as they uh have
have their pin cards to us um we would
ask the speakers to State their name who
they represent for the record submit
copies of any written testimony and
summarize it for the committee and
refrain from repeating what has already
been said if we have many many people
coming to testify I will
certainly remind uh some of the folks
that uh if they've heard something being
said before that they don't need to
repeat it for us so that we're not
hearing the same thing 50 million
times um we may at times uh put in some
time limits for speakers uh sometimes we
had asked them only to testify for about
minutes
um so those you know we we kind of set
the set the ground rules for any
particular
hearing when committee members are
sponsors or co-sponsors of bills some of
you are co-sponsors of bills that may
come or sponsors of bills that may come
to our committee so what happens with
that a Committee Member who is also a
sponsor or co-sponsor of a bill before
the
committee say you sponsor bill you can
come and um introduce the bill to the
committee or you can testify as a
co-sponsor to the
committee um the thing with that is if
you
testify you cannot sit here and an ask
questions of subsequent
um in a moment
a sponsor or co-sponsor who does not
testify may ask questions of other
testimonials so if one exception is if a
bill was filed by the chair me or
another member as a courtesy to an
executive department or the judicial
branch these bills have a line stating
at the top by whose request they were
introduced and um so there's that
representative Penza would you like to
add to that no I well first had a
question for what you said so so if
you're if you're announcing a bill for
no I believe you can yes so uh if if the
sponsor of the bill does not appear to
testify and you are and you are simply
introducing the bill pro forma as a
courtesy for that sponsor who was not
able to make it then
that does not put a limmit on your
ability correct
correct my my other question was um if
you are the uh if you're a co-sponsor or
the main sponsor and you're speaking or
testifying um and you know that there's
other people on the committee that
support your bill um give them the
questions that you want to ask whoever
else is going to testify so you know
somebody that has way too many bills
um is going to have to be working that
to make sure I'm not able to sit here
and ask
questions okay engage your committee
anything
else okay because we're running short on
time now um so for ex we will on
occasion have work work sessions after
we hear testimony on bills and we kind
of want to get a sense of of where the
committee is on that we will have work
sessions prior to having any kind of
exec session on a bill representative
Bixby yeah one more quick note about um
about public input uh there is also a
blue sheet where people can sign in uh
in favor or against a bill where they
when they aren't speaking and there is
an
online uh place where people can sign in
in favor or against bills and we
announced the numbers of uh how many
people signed in on blue sheet and how
many people signed in online for and
against at the end of the hearing on a
bill I would also uh recommend that uh
members of the committee take a look at
the online portal for where uh testimony
is submitted because a lot of times
there are people who will submit
testimony and not come to the committee
and we should read what they have
written so that we know uh what their
thoughts are on that so for executive
they are you know run the same a chair
the chair opens the executive session we
have discussion on bills um we make
motions um to either itl OTP or
whatever retain it refer to interim
study whatever um and the the
uh I will recommend I I will
um um I will then you know ask who who
has the who has a motion to present we
have a discussion on that um and then we
vote on it or we look at amendments uh
on that bill as well and uh look to vote
on those
amendments um so I have the procedure
here on on how executive sessions are
run then of course we have committee
reports so the committee reports are the
little short paragraph blurbs that um
appear in the house calendar when we are
setting as a body in the house to vote
on uh certain
bills and um the person who makes the
motion in exec session for the bill say
uh representative King makes a motion to
itl specif HB 1590 or whatever it is um
he would then be the one to write the
committee report uh if that motion were
to
pass um the committee report is intended
to be a clear concise summary of the
legislation the committee's reason for
making its recommendation they are very
important documents they're permanent
record of the committee's work and the
first opportunity to educate all house
members about the bill when it's printed
uh in the house calendar we don't need
to have the full history of the bill or
you know whatever just uh
brief explanation of um the motion of
the bill what it's
um what its purpose is how it's going to
solve a problem um and brief
statements it yeah explain specifically
how the bill will fix or at least
improve alleviate the problem if it will
cost money include the costs if it saves
money what are the savings um you know
just basic your basic information to let
people know what this bill is all
about uh committee reports should be
done as soon as possible after the exec
session preferably the same day because
we have to get that in and um to our
Administration uh administrative people
um you can transmit it to me
electronically you can give it to me
handwritten bless
you um so that's how the commit
uh committee reports are
written I review those committee I
review those committee reports and I
look to see that they're complete and
that they have um you know correct
information um I don't really take too
uh heavily editing anything and if
something I think needs to be changed
I'll talk to you about it representative
Bixby yeah so uh if you were writing a
committee report for the first second or
you if not you're you're not very
experienced at it then there are more
experienced members of the committee who
will be happy to help you in terms of
phrasing and whatnot uh and so you know
take advantage of the experience on the
committee to um to get some assistance
in writing those until you're feeling
confident on it yourself okay
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair and the committee report uh can be
a majority report or a minority report
because a minority if we have a
difference in voting uh someone may want
to write a Minority Report um but that
still goes through the chair for
review U clarification when we say
majority or minority it the minor is the
majority or minority on the particular
vote for that bill it might be that uh
that it's that it's completely you know
re divorced from any sort of partisan uh
character membership
but it's just who had the most votes on
the B on the vot on Motion versus who
had the the smaller number of votes yeah
we've had majority reports that have
been bipartisan that's fine
representative
Freeman
I'm well the the the committee report is
normally written by the person who made
the amend the uh motion in the exec
session so uh if there's a reason why
they can't write it um they can ask me
and I can do something about that
representative Penza I also wanted to um
during our last session when we voted on
rules someone had brought up about um
making sure that those reports from a
clerk couldn't be modified um I just
wanted everybody in this committee to
know we haven't had any issues with that
at all um there's you know if there's a
grammatical error or something like that
that gets fixed but the content of your
message from a majority or a minority
has never been touched in this committee
I know that it has happened in other
committees that's why that was brought
forward it wasn't a frivolous thing to
say but I want to sure everyone you know
we yeah the best committe yeah well when
I get committee reports from folks and I
need to get some kind of clarification
or something or something doesn't sound
right I will communicate with the person
who wrote the committee report and say
look it can you re can we reword it to
say this and such so we work together on
that collaboration always representative
Bixby yeah and so the the reports
written by the person who makes the
motion uh usually before an executive
session representative Aron and I will
sit down and talk about who's going to
make the motion who's going to make the
seconds on all of the bills we're
discussing and or or that are on the
schedule for the executive session so
and we will then um sort of bring up we
will ask members of our caucuses uh who
wants to make motions on particular
bills so that um you're not going to be
suddenly uh learning that you're going
to be making the motion and you're going
to be make writing the report about
something you know without any you know
prior knowledge it's all it's pretty
uh thank you madam chair I assume it's
not a requirement that a Minority Report
be written how is that handled in this
committee representative Bixby so uh the
people who are on the minority of a vote
decide amongst themselves whether
they're going to write a report and
who's going to do it uh and sometimes
there'll be a situation where uh
there was a minority vote but it wasn't
something that people cared an awful lot
about and they'll just let it slide on
on the other hand there might be a
minority vote and it might be a minority
of one but that person cares an awful
lot in which case there'll be a Minority
Report sure and then we'll also um agree
as to whether something would go on
consent or not and of course there would
have to be a um um a committee report to
go along uh with that
representative King and um sometimes
there can be a a minority position that
will still allow it to go to consent
calendar y y
so right as long as if there's a
Minority Report it can't go in consent
but if there's a if let's say two people
just vote against the bill uh if they
say during the executive section we're
okay with this being on consent then it
can still go on consent right okay are
we clear on that all right
good uh okay last thing field
trips we typically organize farm and
other related tours and we have in the
past and we will give plenty of notice
on when and where um these tours will
take place in fact I do have
um I do have a request
from um Rob Johnson from Farm Bureau
about whether or not the committee would
like to have uh the young Farmers
breakfast in March or April so that is
something that we're going to have to uh
figure out and talk to talk about but
we've already been invited to uh to do
the farm
breakfast um so when we have these field
trips we hope that committee members
will participate and come uh you will
likely get mileage for those field trips
and those trips are designed to help you
increase our knowledge on various issues
last year we visited um landfills we
went uh to visit UNH extension green
houses we've done a bunch of different
interesting things representative Howard
I just wanted to say that I attended
every field trip last time and highly
relevant and very interesting and learn
okay so that's pretty much us in a in a
nutshell um you'll certainly have
questions as we go along as will I and
uh we you know we we've got a lot of
really good uh good work ahead of us I
look forward to working with everybody
and I'm going to call an a meeting to
adjourn for now and return at 1 o'clock
when we will begin
having 1:00 we have agency heads and
other folks
uh from Department of Agriculture Dees
and also uh DHHS Food Safety Division
coming in this afternoon to give us
presentations on who they are what they
do or what they think they
do what we think they do and it'll give
us an opportunity also to meet them and
ask ask questions and um I it will be a
very informative afternoon and I hope
that you will return here and 1:00 talk
and partake of that so thank you I
appreciate all your attention this
morning and it has been delightful
meeting you
all I'll see if I can get these uh
here
test
e
testing testing this one sounds testing
one
two
e
around
you okay good afternoon members take
your your seats please and first I want
to make an announcement I there was a
tie clip that was uh returned does
anybody know might be his no it's not
yours huh okay let's see if we'll put
that by his
seat we've got uh couple of members I
don't know I know Jonah was on his way
up and J on his way
up Nick won't be
here uh okay well it's 1:00 I'm going to
here welcome to environment and
Agriculture and this afternoon we are
going to have a uh a
full afternoon of um presentations by
the agencies that we work with in this
committee so for the benefit of our new
members and then a refresher for some of
our
veterans uh we will have first up at uh
at bat here is uh commissioner Jasper
from Department of Agriculture markets
and
food so commissioner
out
go would you like people to hold
questions till the end or ask them as we
go along how would you like to do
this so it would probably if they what
we're going to do is I'm just going to
get up here and do an overview I'm glad
to take any initial questions but um
there will be a representative from each
division who will be up there speaking
probably if there are questions specific
to the divisions it would be appropriate
to uh ask questions of them at the end
if we have time and there are more
questions I'll come back up again to
answer uh if I can more broad questions
so okay thank you but if you have any
initial questions on on my overview
please feel free to to let me know so
good afternoon I am Sean Jasper
commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food uh and just
from a historical perspective there have
been Commissioners since January 1st of
uh 1914 and I am the sth
commissioner I don't think you'll find
that low number in any other agency
that's been around for a while before
you continue can everybody hear well
enough yeah okay good enough very good
thank you um I have with me uh Rebecca
Ross who is the director of agricultural
uh development and she will be running
the slideshow here for us and speaking
at to her division at some point Thank
you and and also can everybody see the
screen while enough and we do have okay
black and white uh copies of of the
slides being handed out and around here
someplace as the chairman indicated I
have uh put a stack of my business cards
out there um and please feel free and I
would encourage you to to to call me
anytime also to please come by uh to
Granite
Place uh and visit the department
anytime so we can give you a better
understanding of what we what we do and
where we're located uh and you all you
folks will all be over there next next
year next January y so uh right most of
the hearings are going to be right on
the same floor as we are we'll be seeing
a lot of you and U that'll be a good
thing so
um just an overview of the department
you know I'm not going to read our
mission you can do that but you can see
we have six full divisions although
really
uh fsma which is food safety
modernization act is a uh a small
division directly under me nobody wanted
to take it on when we took it over from
uh Health and Human Services so I am
really acting as the division head on on
that we have 44 approved positions when
I came on as commissioner in December of
17 we had 32 filled positions with 38
authorized and as of today we have 44
filled positions um we are we have no
vacancies in the department and uh we
also have added over that period of time
a lead
it uh individual who technically works
for Department of uh Information
Technology but is embedded and has his
office there uh he will also be working
with Jud judicial Council which is on
the same
floor as we are so
[Music]
um let me
see y so you're going to hear from
everybody except uh bismo the food
safety modernization act uh which is
fully Federal federally funded if the
feds pull the funding the program goes
away but that's where we go out and we
do uh inspections on any place that is
growing food that is being consumed our
primary focus is on food that is ready
to eat to make sure that that food is
handled properly so that in fact you
know there there aren't problems with
that we're less concerned about food
that has to be cooked um but regardless
we
do take a great deal of care in making
sure that everything is done according
to the best standards
where do I go from
there the next Slide the overview of
course we're promoting and regulating
all branches of Agriculture regulating
commercial transactions involving
weights distance volume of time volume
and time um I would gather to say or
dare to say perhaps that you probably
don't go more than a day or two without
doing something that we
regulate um you'll find out about the
fact that
any measuring or weighing device is
regulated by us and you'll hear more
about that from from that division um
and so we really have our hands on
things that you know people don't
understand until they really delve into
it um the we regulate the grade and
quality of agricultural
crops uh gather information disseminate
that we we do a lot of cooperation with
other
agencies um our sister organization if
you will is really coopera Cooperative
Extension at the University of New
Hampshire we have great relationship
with Cooperative Extension and work with
them we have contracts but there are
times when they just say hey you need
help we'll help you for instance when we
when we first got into um the whole
problem during the pandemic and the
federal money that we had there
um they just hopped in and helped and
there were no charges uh to us on that
so it's a great organization at the
University and I'm pleased to say that
as of July 1
um The Cooperative Extension will be
back
under um College of life science and
agriculture which it has not been for a
while thankfully the new president UNH
who came from land grant school and
understood
that um was very receptive to that idea
when I mentioned it to her and said we
really need to do this and there's a lot
of good good reasons and she's made it
happen so very pleased with that and
then of course we do whatever else the
legislature tells us to do to the best
of our ability including pet vending
which we would really rather not be
doing so the budget overview I think is
pretty important this this last year our
total authorized spending is just over
$9
million 4.9 million comes from the
general
fund 2.9 from other almost three million
from other sources and uh
1.1 from federal funds but I would note
that the total unrestricted revenues
that were projected to bring in for this
year is over $6
million you compare that to the general
fund of just under 5 5 million we
actually make money for the general
fund so
we um take in more money than what you
give us General funds so that makes it
really difficult when we're asked to do
budget cuts because we're a profit
Center and of course if resources are
taken from us it's more difficult for us
to actually then produce that Revenue
that you've asked us to
produce um and with that unless there
are any broad questions I'll uh yes
representative Bixby so um do the
unrestrict do the other funds include uh
um dedicated
funds uh yes I believe they I believe
they do I should have asked that
question
specifically um I don't know Josh do you
do uh one of the things that we did last
term was
uh shift more money from that was
generated by income by fee income to a
dedicated fund which is directly under
the department rather than having to go
through the general fund
correct thank
you uh representative
sopus hello um is part of this um from
animal food pet food a great deal of it
is when director Wyman is up here he can
speak more specifically to that thank
you representative
Penza do you have these just um um
overview figures going back as well that
would be easily accessible not like
right the second but like that could be
sent to the committee I think it would
be helpful to see this over a period of
time I do not have knowledge that we do
I don't have knowledge that we don't
when I get back I will see what we have
available and see if we can send you
that information great just to see a
comparison over right I think we can we
can pull that up certainly over the last
five or six years should that' be great
thank you should be easy to
do what what where what portion of where
and what portion of the funds go to fund
the Diagnostic lab
[Music]
so wasn't prepared for that
question I think that there is an income
stream
within um
our I want to say it may come
from dog licensing I'll get you a
specific on that but it's not a general
fund appropriation as I I recall but
there is an appropriation and that is
another thing that technically the
Commissioner of Agriculture has uh
budgetary oversight over the Diagnostic
lab at un yeah I I'm particularly
interested to know for the money that's
taken in
where that money comes from and how that
money funds the Diagnostic lab I I I
believe we had I think in the past we
had bills that came to our committee and
it was indicated that um good portion of
the dog licensing does go to fund the
Diagnostic lab that is my
recollection sorry go
ahead yeah yeah okay uh representative K
I'm sorry thank you madam chair thank
you commissioner for being here um and I
know you don't probably do not have the
answer on this but I'm just going to ask
it to the entire department there um
with other funds and it includes
dedicated funds can we get a breakdown
of the dedicated funds and what dollars
are in those um so that we could see
that certainly we do have we do have
that
information and um I will note on these
dedicated funds that
um we have made things more transparent
part of that was through bill that you
passed last year um the the amount of
money in there um not huge we've pulled
a lot out since I become commissioner
for specific things and in general we
anticipate that because of the shift in
in funding and how we're funding it
those numbers will continue to come down
um about three budget ago I I said this
is not sustainable to do it this way but
because of what we've been asked um in
the budget process we are pulling those
down which I I think in general is
reasonable but at some point the
chickens will come home to roost and we
may not have enough money depending on
where our Revenue stream goes from I
think we've done a pretty good job and
things are working out pretty well but
those those funds are being used to fund
the programs um that the money comes in
from uh and we are not building those
those funds up any any longer which they
were uh they had been previously
followup yes Madam chair thank you
um so I've been hearing stuff about the
cost of care fund um because I'm
assuming that is one of those dedicated
funds um can you tell us where we stand
with that is that fully funded at the
moment or do we are we how that's thank
you it's it's not fully funded um I
think fully funded I think our our
number we would hope to get it up into I
don't remember what the mil the number
is now but in the in the
millions it is um well under a million
right now I just had another small batch
of requests come in but
unfortunately um we will be putting very
little into the fund in the next
biennium because that's the first place
any of our are funding the fair
the funding for land purchases the the
fund for uh fairs and the fund for um
cost of care pulled those down to about
$25,000 a year roughly 20 25,000 a year
each uh and if we're asked to make
further cuts um that'll be the next to
go because I'm not going to to be
funding these these things and laying
off people we have a mission to do when
it takes people to to accomplish that
mission thank you very much I appreciate
it thank
you okay all right with that I will turn
it over to director Russo from the
control good afternoon honorable members
of the environment and agriculture
committee I'm David rouso I see the
division of pesticide control pesticide
control being one of the divisions
within the
I'll give you a quick overview of what
does bottom line is the protection of
human health and the environment while
recognizing the benefits of pesticides
so there's a mission statement there but
really the bottom line is to protect
human health and the environment while
recognizing the benefit of pesticides
I'm proud to say that New Hampshire was
one of the first state programs in
regards to pesticide control in the
nation we're talking about Roots back
into the 1960s predate the Environmental
Protection Agency at the federal level
as well as the Department of
Environmental Services so the department
really jumped on board quickly with
those with that manager protection of
human health and the
environment now I was thinking if I was
sitting in your seat what would be
helpful for me to remember the division
of pesticide control so if there's one
thing you could remember we have a
licensing component so people that go on
to someone else's property and use pesti
decides they need to have a license
there's an exam standard it's a written
closed book exam so if there's one thing
you can remember there is a license
requirement for folks that go on to
other people's property and use
pesticides as well as private use of
pesticides to create a commod commodity
so agriculture so licensing then I
thought well there's two things maybe
there's two things not just one but
there's product registration we register
all products that are used as pesticides
in the state um and that results in in a
dedicated fund 75% of that goes to the
general fund 25% stand stays in What's
called the integrated Pest Management so
just those two things if you remember
two things just remember people have to
be licensed exam requirement and and
this product reg and then the third
thing I think there ought to be a third
one and that would be the enforcement
piece so we actually have an enforcement
team that goes out and makes sure that
people that have a license are doing
things properly as well as we respond to
complaints okay so there's a licensing
part there's a product registration part
and there is the enforcement part and
then the last thing I want you to
remember we do some education and
Outreach definitely uh the commissioner
mentioned our partnership with the
University of New Hampshire we actually
met with them yesterday at the end of
this month we'll do a number of training
sessions for people that are interested
in uh getting a license or folks that
already have a license that need to
maintain credits so you you maintain
recertification credits to avoid taking
the exam okay so that a nutshell is is
is some of the activity we we we are
involved with and how do we do this how
many people do we use to do this we have
eight folks fulltime
um one uh two of them are pesticide
inspectors and you got a great bang for
your buck with two inspectors in the
state I'll get to the numbers later on
it's how many inspections they do um we
have an environmental program four out
of the eight uh employees are carry the
environmentalist title and I think
that's important for the type of work we
do we're talking about chemicals in the
environment um five of the eight folks
in the division actually have
environmental degrees so either it's a
wildlife biology natural resource
protection environmental planning so
we're we're really focused an
environmental concern focused group um
we have one certification coordinator
that manages the licensing
piece we have one individual that does
the product
registration we have a program assistant
now don't let that title fool you that
person actually has two degrees one in
natural resources and one in vet tech so
um well qualified individuals with an i
Division and then and then this the
director
I could just quickly go through some of
our major programs from last year I mean
uh deliverables from last year based on
our major
programs the licensing we issued 2600
licenses most of those are what we call
Commercial and that's the people that go
on other people's property so there's
about 2200 of those licens that are
issued the others are the agricultural
type so about four just just under
um and the education and Outreach
component is part of that licensing
program uh the product registration
piece we registered 13,000 products last
year and again that's one individual
taking care of that program and
fortunately as a uh as a nation we work
closely together with other states so
where we only have one person doing
product registration there may be a
larger state that has a whole staff
focused on that so if there's a problem
with a pesticide we usually hear about
it quickly and that's an important piece
to the program uh so product
registration again compliance Assurance
which is our enforcement we had two
inspectors in the field last year over
600 inspections which is a good number
they also um in addition to doing random
checks so they'll show up if someone's
about ready to use a pesticide they'll
do what we call the use observation
they're taking notes they're checking
licenses making things sure things are
done properly and they also respond to
complaints so the inspections are done
mostly for random checks on folks with
licenses but we also respond to
complaints as far as Environmental
Protection
goes we spend a lot of time with water
quality resource protection and there's
a thing called special permits that
these license holders will need for
certain work that they do I'll give you
an example sometimes W uh water is in is
a situation where a pesticide might be
used in water to control weeds so that
would require a special permit very
involved very heavily regulated we want
to know who's doing it how they're doing
it what they're using what time of day
they're doing it give us a chance to
inspect if needed we sample water so the
environmental piece is really important
uh there's also setback requirements for
people that use pesticides and if they
want to get within that setback they
would need a special permit if we'd
allow it at all um so Environmental
Protection really important and then the
last program I wanted to mention is the
integrated Pest Management program if
you're not familiar with that as the
name implies integrated we're
integrating a number of methods to
control a pest so it's not just the
pesticide it might be a mechanical
approach it might be a cultural approach
but it's it's the it's an activity uh to
address a pest other than just one using
one me method so we do have some money
into that program and we issue about six
four to six grants a year um and I could
I could get carried away with that I got
to move the page quickly or I'll go
director um so pesticides includes
herbicides correct yeah I should have I
should have given you a definition right
off right off it is in the statute and
the rules a pesticide is really a
chemical and it could be organic or a
combination of chemicals used to control
a pest under that umbrella of pesticides
you have herbicides which would be for
PL plants you have insecticides for
insects fungicides for fungus and on and
on and on so pesticide would be the
umbrella term herbicide does go
underneath that that and that's part of
our regulation thank
you um and yeah last couple things I
wanted to mention was we do partner with
other state agencies we work closely
with Department of Environmental
Services Fish and Game Transportation
natural cult cultural resources and as I
mentioned the university um and we work
really closely with the federal
government especially the Environmental
Protection Agency the the national
umbrella law is is at the federal level
and they support about 40% of our
program so we work closely with the
Environmental Protection Agency as well
as the United States Department of
Agriculture now the board um we have a
pesticide control board is it's a by
Statute of 13 member board and they
oversee the regulations and the policies
of the division and that's really all I
have unless is are there any vacancies
on that board right now yes there are
how many uh four
and those are made via appointment by
the
governor yes all of those are Governor
appointment thank
you I'm sorry Kelly uh represent pens
I'm sorry pardon
me sorry oh it's working our mics
weren't working before um thank you for
coming in your presentation I just had a
question about the 2600 licenses so
let's say if I own um a pesticide
business and I have you know 100
employees is that included in there like
the licenses for each one of those
individual people that are going out and
and applicating product yes that's
correct okay
yeah representative com thank you madam
chair and thank you for being here how
are you um
so just for folks to understand and on
the individual or say
um pesticide licenses if you're on
Farm if you're selling your produce to a
consumer and you're using either an
organic or non-organic chemical are you
required to have a license yes the way
the the law identifies the use of
chemical and chemical includes organic
correct um so you would need a a per a
pesticide permit to use organic
materials to raise if you're if you're
using that material to control a pest
that would require a
permit thank you uh thank you for that
thank you madam chair yeah I just wanted
to uh ask that because I think it's
important for everyone to understand um
how our license works and also the fact
that there's an annual reporting so
you're keeping track of how many how
what pesticides have been used in wear
is that correct yes part of the license
requirement to maintain is to report
annually what you use that year one more
okay one more thank you madam chair and
um does the pesticide control board in
New Hampshire have the right to not
allow a pesticide into New Hampshire
even if it's federally approved yes
thank you okay representative
Penza representative Conan now just open
up a whole can of question worm so no um
okay so I have to to understand
this for you to be able to
you know um apply any sort of pesticides
on your property Farm or something like
that you have to have a license if the
commodity is is being sold or
distributed okay so are there so for
example if you if you're working for a
company that does this does everyone
that is applying have to have a license
in that situation no the one person
would be required to have the license
and be in direct contact with the
individuals using it if if the choice
was to let people apply the pesticide
under that one license but they would
probably be on site like supervising
corre okay um I think that's it okay
representative King thank you madam
chair thank you director um do you buy a
chance have an idea of what percentage
of pesticides are herbicides fungicides
and insecticides roughly not off the top
of my head but I could I could get you
that information yeah yeah
representative Bixby Okay so so um if
we're talking about a
pest uh a pest control
company uh would there be one one
licensing level for the management of
the company and then the the employees
who are actually going out in the field
would have a different level of
license correct every business entity as
we call them commercial business entity
requires at least one individual to have
a supervisory level licensees the and
it's an advanced level license then
under that supervisory they can add an
operational level both supervisory and
operational are required to take the
written exam the supervisory is held to
a standard of what's called an oral exam
so after that supervisory candidate
passes the written test they sit before
a panel um of individuals to to to allow
that supervisory license to be
satisfied and just a little bit of
clarification in terms of the
Agricultural and things you said that uh
not everyone would actually have to have
a license who was applying things if
they were underneath the management of a
uh someone who had a supervisory license
the private is different the
agricultural piece is there's no oral
exam requirement there is a written Clos
book exam for folks that use restricted
use products or what's called worker
protection standard type products we're
getting into the Weeds now sorry but
they could be they they could be on site
and have some that doesn't have a
license but they need to work together
so the responsibility Falls to that
license holder in the in the
agricultural example okay thank you
representative
Scully thank you madam chair and thank
you for coming to testify um what is the
period of um how long is a license valid
for and does that 2600 number include
people who are being
relicensed um after a license expires
great so the license is good for five
years as long as you renew annually so
you're submitting what you used for that
year you're asking for the license for
the second year you have five years to
accumulate a certain number of credits
to avoid the exam so you're on a
fiveyear cycle but you have to renew it
annually and the 2600 would be uh I I
would have to um go back and find out
how many of those are new versus how
many are are renewing okay thank you
thanks
good afternoon members of the committee
again for the record my name is Rebecca
Ross I'm the director of agricultural
development and I've been in this
position since August so bear with me I
don't have the experience that the
commissioner and David have with their
program areas but we'll we'll try to get
through it for everybody um so unlike
the other divisions in the division of a
development we're not a regular atory
division we're sort of the everything
else when it comes to connecting um
producers and consumers and supporting
the egg industry in New
Hampshire so our mission is to create
Market development opportunities that
result in increased sales for
producers um provide information to the
public and inform the public of the
value and diversity of the state's
agricultural herit and Industry so not
only what you can buy today but what
value it provides to our state whether
it's travel and tourism land protection
all of those things that make New
Hampshire New Hampshire because of its
Rich agricultural history in order to do
that our core functions include
administering a number of different
federal grants that support producers
and the folks that are also supporting
producers whether it's trade Industries
or the folks at un doing research that
will support that continued production
in New Hampshire um our office also
supports public
inquiries um and we produce and
disseminate information and directories
we're shifting for efficiency purposes
to doing a lot of that online and having
links to directories that can be updated
more than once of once a year and not
printing things that we then have to
dispose of and reprint as soon as there
are a couple of changes so we're trying
to do that as efficiently as possible
but we know people want to just Google
where do I find this near me and have
that information and we're working with
Partners to make sure that's available
um we also manage the states building at
the Big E which is New Hampshire
property that we own in Massachusetts as
well as participate in other events and
fairs and Expos to promote Agriculture
and the folks working in agriculture we
have three and a half um full-time
employees or three and a half FTE
including my position as the Director
one person who supports our weekly
Market Bulletin which is our publication
with eg information that goes out
Statewide to subscribers um one person
who manages reception and banking issues
deposits um and is really the the face
of Agriculture who supports all of the
divisions as we have individuals walking
in and asking questions and trying to
get information um and an information
representative which is a part-time
position that helps us put together
those directories support our online
presence and support um our our grants
in different programs throughout the
division um specifically the specialty
crop block grants from USDA are a huge
part of our work um this past year we
were managing 24 different projects each
year we get a new allocation that we put
put out in a competitive process for
people supporting agriculture it does
not go to individual producers and have
a few projects that are supported um
which go three plus years so throughout
the course of any Year we're supporting
20 to 25 projects although they're each
from different years that overlap so
that's how we get to the TW total of 24
projects um those uh will be coming up
again in a couple months for the next
2025 allocation and the next bidding
process for those projects the other
large programs that are a little bit
newer and haven't been going on as long
are local food to schools and local food
purchase assistance both of which are
being reup by the feds the dollar
amounts for those programs um in the
coming years are in those slides for the
local food to schools program they're
also adding a component that will go to
early childhood to help ensure um the
institutions that are serving and
supporting our kids during the day have
support and connections to buy um
healthy foods from local producers so
we're seeing another three years for
that program we partner with the food
bank on the local F food purchase
assistance program which is also being
reup for another three years so if the
federal funding for those programs goes
away the program goes away yes yes
exactly so um they were both new
programs a few years ago and up until
last month it wasn't 100% that we would
see another round we have seen the the
notices um that they give us the
opportunity to apply to participate for
another three years thank you
representative
Miner thank you madam chairman uh thank
you director a question uh with the
grants what what types of Grants do you
um do you guys fund uh is it is it for
local Farmers is it for large
corporations exactly not exactly but
what types of uh grants do you fund sure
so it these are not to individual
producers they're either to
organizations well they're to
organizations that are supporting
agriculture it maybe a Trade
Organization um last year one of the
awards was to the New Hampshire
Beekeepers Association where they will
then be doing subg grants to 10
different um entities throughout the
state to promote good practices and
education within their communities um we
send usually there's each round there's
a couple to researchers as well so there
is one project right now looking at
researching um older strawberry
varieties and bringing back some of
those healthy genes that will thrive in
the environment that we have now so it's
either research or promotion on a
Statewide level versus an individual
producer
than you followup yeah y thank you again
um what a what an organization like fa
FFA be a organization that would get
some of this grant money um we fund FFA
with some other money if they had a
project that was going to promote and
meet the standards to promote specialty
crops that
USDA puts forth they could certainly
apply and and be in the running for that
historically in the last few years we
have not seen that thank you
go
ahead oh representative Bixby had a
question so uh I get the Market Bulletin
I've been getting it pretty much since I
joined this was a me started on this
committee I was wondering is that
something that you automatically put on
uh on the email for all of the members
of this committee and if it's if it
isn't now could that be become the
case yes you so you're asking if if we
can have the entire membership on the
Market Bulletin subscription list by
email yes we will do that thank you
thank
you
okay all right so in addition to the
grant work that we do um that is really
focused Statewide we do have the
individual initiatives that we're
involved with including the Big E if
you're not familiar with the big e um it
is a Fair in Springfield Massachusetts
that had that runs for 17 days is one of
the largest fairs in the country um way
back when the um promoter or developer
of the Big E thought it was important to
promote all of the New England states so
each of the New England states owns
property in a building to sh showcase
their own State at that fair we own a
building that um was open for the 17
days of the fair last year the the foot
traffic during those 17 days was
1.6 million people we have a large
partnership ship with travel and tourism
and um the New Hampshire ambassadors
that are down there talking to all of
those guests that are coming through our
building we also had 22 booths with 17
different vendors there's one day
dedicated to each state and on New
Hampshire day we also had um six
performer six performances by three
different groups and additional
exhibitors showing their trades or
products um so we're looking to always
build up how we're promoting New
Hampshire through the new New England
states um which directly connects to our
our travel and tourism in support of
Agriculture as those folks are coming to
visit our state um we also support the
form Farm forest and garden expo which
has shifted from being in downtown
Manchester to the Deerfield fa
Fairgrounds to have much more of an
agricultural uh feel and to be um in
that outside environment to give better
opportunities to to Showcase that
agriculture handson um the last large
part of our division's work is really um
all of the Publications and promotions
whether it's using some of that Grant
fund to partner with the ad agencies
that we work with to promote those
specialty crops um producing The Market
Bulletin updating our website and
directories and working with other
contractors on TV radio and online ads
reminding people of the value of
Agriculture and where to find it here
New Hampshire each year we're looking to
update that and sort of refresh those
this particular Year we're also starting
a contract to do some branding and
create a logo for local New Hampshire
products just like many other states
have done so you'll see that coming out
in the next few months okay so this
might be a very weird question I'll
throw it out to you as well as the
commissioner does your
department division of agricultural
development
have any kind of metrics to do to
determine the success of the work that
you're doing and other words are you
measuring how many new Farms are
established or how many people that you
reach during a given year or something
like that do you have metrics that
determine your division's
success that's a great question and was
one of my first questions when I came
over here and those are hard things to
measure we have some more on an
individual level so we have a lot of
USDA data and statistics we have
individual metrics in the different
grants um we have reports from the
contractors that are doing some of the
advertising on number of hits number of
sort of not only did they view it but
did they engage so number of engagements
so we can we can see how much activity
is on a lot of our external things what
we haven't been able to do is see it on
our own website which is a bit of a
challenge we are in the process of
revamping the department's website as
well we're drafting all of those pages
now that will give us better metrics on
who's looking for What on our website
and who is engaging which I think will
be very helpful um and then we're we're
always looking to to have surveys to
partner with UNH and and other partners
the operative extensions and the
conservation commissions on their
numbers but being careful not to over
assume on causal connections too right
we have a great campaign we have five
more Farms we don't know that our
campaign or a certain program really had
anything to do with influencing that we
have five more Farms or we don't so I
think it's a little bit more narrow but
that's certainly a focus of mind to make
sure that what we're doing is Statewide
is true to the mission and that we can
show those outcomes because you know we
all recognize the value of educating the
public in um how important agriculture
is to New Hampshire but I think we also
need to
know how well we are doing in trying to
get more Farms established and going and
becoming successful because more Farms
we have the better I believe anyway two
cents as a farmer I would agree I think
we're also you know going to be looking
at what other states are looking at and
not necessarily do we have more but are
we not losing because we are losing
dairy farms we are losing a land and we
are losing producers and so sometimes
the status quo is the positive metric
because we haven't shifted back
especially in the higher density areas
um so looking at what we can do to make
sure that we continue to support what we
have and take measures to gain I so are
you doing any kind of reports or studies
to show why we are losing farmlands or
da Farms or why we are not successful in
any one particular aspect of agriculture
in the state um our division is not
supporting any specifically right now I
think i' look to Josh and the
commissioner about what we've done in
the past I know there have been studies
that have been done every every few
years um but it's certainly on our radar
to make sure we're looking at that going
forward thank you any other questions
representative King thank you madam
chair and thank you director the Big E
building that New Hampshire owns um is
that vacant the other 348 days a year
and do we pay property taxes to the
state of Massachusetts thank you we do
not pay property taxes to the state of
Massachusetts and I inherited a lot of
files on the history of that um it yes
it is vacant the rest of the year in
aent shut down for the representative K
thank you madam chair and thank you
director and welcome uh to the ENA uh
committee I know this is your first time
here um speaking of the Big E um with
the vendors and the booth in there
they're all from New Hampshire selling
New Hampshire products is that correct
you ask mate to come join us for um
industry I'm sorry what was his name
what was your name uh Nate Harvey h a r
v
y hi everybody uh thanks for having us
this is my first time presenting to you
my name is Nate Harvey and I'm the
assistant State veterinarian for the
Department of Agriculture typically you
guys would be hearing from the state
veterinarian who you all know well Dr
Steve Crawford he's out of town today so
I'm sitting in for him um think I'll
just follow the slides as we go so um I
am going to read to you the mission for
our division the division of animal
industry um we prevent and control
contagious and infectious diseases of
livestock and poultry for the benefit of
Public Health and the economy uh that's
important because the emphasis is on
infectious and contagious diseases
particularly so diseases that are
communicable between animals and can
spread among our state and damage our
state's economy our state's animal
industry and cause public health
problems that is different than a
disease that might be say a birth defect
if your puppy was born with a crooked
tail or if your cow was born with
something abnormal that's not going to
be contagious or risk anybody's economy
or public health so it's important to
remember that component of our mission
and we we do experience challenges with
that uh every day in terms of people
trying to understand what that means
infectious and contagious um so how do
we do that uh we have several core
functions that we pursue so we conduct
investigations of animal disease
outbreaks on farms and in certain uh
licensed facilities basically anytime
there's an outbreak or an appearance
that there may be disease present that's
where we get called um to livestock
facilities and uh any kind of facility
that would potentially affect our our
food our public Public Health our Farms
as we've just been discussing and
sometimes even our pets uh we run lots
of Diagnostics both routinely uh when
there are not outbreaks happening so
what we call Peace time uh we run lots
of Diagnostics throughout the state on a
regular basis a voluntary basis among
many of our Farms our poultry producers
our livestock producers and sometimes
even our pet producers um that may be
just disease management um watching for
tuberculosis or brucelosis uh it may be
um assisting to transport or test uh for
rabies another very important disease in
the state but we do have the capability
to run a lot of Diagnostics and we do
that in conjunction with the uh New
Hampshire veterinary Diagnostic lab uh
we communicate regularly with our state
EOC because often times large
animal large scale animal emergencies
can become human emergencies and
sometimes large scale human emergencies
can also become animal emergencies uh so
we work with them regularly on response
plans um everything from uh potential
situations say with a seab brick nucle
nuclear power plant to the introduction
of a foreign animal disease something
very highly contagious um to the
introduction of a disease that would be
significantly zoonatic and risk uh the
human population we work with the EOC
regularly on practicing and managing
plans like that um and most importantly
probably the most common thing we do is
we regulate and oversee animal movement
so for myself as a veteran Arian coming
from 177 years of practice where I
worked on fixing the individual animal
or the herd with the problem uh it's a
different kind of work because we
monitor the movement we make sure the
animals have the appropriate regulatory
paperwork to cross state lines or to
even move within our state we make sure
they have the appropriate required legal
um the testing required to move and we
make sure especially if there's a change
in ownership of an animal a transfer of
an animal that that appropriate
paperwork uh comes as well because the
person and purchasing the animal uh may
not uh have all the background um we do
a lot with animal population we have the
animal population control program which
I'll talk about in a second and within
our division we have nine full-time
employees we have the state veterinarian
we have myself the assistant State
veterinarian we have four animal health
technicians essentially Veterinary
technicians doing regulatory work so we
call them animal health technicians we
have a full-time disease data management
entry person and our office manager and
the a PCP the man animal population
control Pro program overseer so next
slide so how do we do Disease Control we
I talked about Disease Control is the
most important thing we do how do we do
that we do that with the authority
provided in RSA 436 and some of other
statutes and we typically will conduct
testing and
investigations in so far as available
funds permit but also in so far as the
reason to believe that that disease may
exist there so we do not just go around
the the state looking for diseases
except for our routine um Disease
Control programs that we have for
diseases that we know we are under
constant threat of and our animals are
um we don't go barging into people's
property just trying to find a disease
there we need to have a reason to
believe that it's there based on our
fellow colleagues other agencies or
animal symptoms and signs notifications
from veterinarians local law enforcement
things like that um so that's how we do
that that's the authority under which we
do that um why zootic disease zuntic
disease means a disease that is
transferred from an animal to a human
and so just to let you know the
importance of that term 61% of all germs
that we know as humans all the germs uh
that humans can catch 61% of those are
zoonotic meaning that they can be
transferred from animals to people
75% of all the emerging zoonotic disease
outbreaks right now in the world that
means new diseases that we're trying to
figure out study and understand create
vaccines for 75% of those new ones are
zoonotic they're related to animals or
animal transmission to people and lastly
the most important statistic in the
United States seven out of 10 American
households have pets or livestock or
animals right in their immediate
vicinity um so that's the importance of
why we regulate Animal Health a lot of
people fail to realize that the main
purpose is to protect human
health um so obviously overseeing food
safety food security regulatory costs
and taxpayer implications anytime
there's an animal outbreak or a disease
or anytime we even have to conduct an
animal disease Trace back to try to
figure out if there's a disease or an
outbreak happening that all costs money
and takes time and a lot of resources um
and then the disposal event and
controlling and biocurity after an
outbreak is important and that's that's
all the reasons why it's important we
regulate Animal Health um we have
regular programs for rabies tuberculosis
salmonella avien influenza mic plasma
brucelosis Scrapy um and a numerous uh
numerous other diseases those are all
regularly monitored diseases that we
look for to try to prevent them from
building up in our herds in the state of
New Hampshire so do you work in
conjunction with fishing gam so they
come across a moose and that's deceased
and they do they contact you to try and
figure out why it died or that's a great
question that exact example you
mentioned a moose maybe not so much
unless it was found on a dairy herd or
is found in relation to uh one of our
livestock animals however um a wild uh
Canadian goose or uh uh if there
certainly was a wild pig a feral hog
found or something in relation to our
farms uh something that is known to have
a direct infectious agent that we 100%
know is high-risk to our dairy farms and
our swine Farms we would absolutely be
involved with fishing game we we
communicate regularly with fishing game
we don't do a lot too much with moose uh
we we do have some things we do with
servid the the term served means deer or
elk or Caribou um but yes we do
regularly work with uh USDA and uh
fishing game um USDA wildlife services
another Wildlife uh component that we
work with a lot regularly especially
here in conquer so for example if if I
have a constituent who found a dead
turkey wild turkey on their property yes
and maybe they've got you know flock of
chickens or something nearby or whatever
should they call your office that's a
real that's a real situation that
happens quite a bit actually because the
turkey is wild they first should call
fishing game they absolutely first
should call fishing game and fish and
game will communicate with them about uh
collect whether that bird is a
considered a suspect bird or high enough
risk bird to test because we find
Wildlife all the time a dead bat uh dead
turkey that kind of thing the fishing
game has thresholds that they set and a
whole entire decision algorithm for when
the risk is high enough that they need
to intervene because we do find wild
animals quite a bit sometimes just the
one off and it doesn't always mean
something might be happening in terms of
an infectious disease so they should
first Contact fishing game fishing game
would then assess do their algorithm and
discussion with them and call us uh
which happens sometimes if exactly the
parameters you just mentioned happen
like there's a susceptible flock of
poultry nearby maybe there's more than
one dead turkey maybe two or three dead
in the neighborhood um so yes it's
possible we'd get called but the first
if it's a wild animal the first call
should go to fish and game if it's a
domestic bird of course should go to us
to what extent does your department or
fishing
game um educate the public in how to go
about doing that that's a great question
we we um we have Flyers out there we
have a um our decision-making algorithm
for that what we use um to determine for
example if an animal might be at risk
for rabies we get calls all the time I
found a dead rat in my basement could my
cat or dog be getting rabies from this
or I found a a dead bat in my house that
my cat was playing with do I need to
worry about rabies that the the
decision-making process we use comes
from statute it's spelled out in laws
and rules and we actually use our
decision-making algorithm we've kind of
published it into a flyer and we make
that public so we will share that with
law enforcement ACO or even the public
um W Wildlife has the same thing very
similar algorithms and there's not only
a hotline you can call it all the time
but posters and um public messaging
especially amongst an outbreak if we
start having an outbreak of West Al
virus or highly pathogenic Aven
influenza which I'll talk about in a
second we we do release materials not
only on our website um but uh kind of
these little Flyers that we make in
conjunction with New Hampshire
veterinary Diagnostic lab wildlife
services and other agencies thank you um
so moving on to Disease Control so we
work regularly with the uh Veterinary
Diagnostic lab It's a Wonderful team
over there of very smart Veterinary
Pathologists a lot smarter than I'll
ever be and a team of people that are
experts in animal disease and diagnostic
testing we work with them regularly
bringing them samples we communicate
with them regularly about results that
we get uh for animals that are submitted
for disease testing uh like I mentioned
we communicate regularly with our
Emergency Operations Center and the
Emergency Operations people that will
essentially be overseeing uh response if
we have a state emergency uh involving
animal disease um and we uh you'll see
on the third bar there under disease
control we regulate livestock dealers
poultry dealers and Swine garbage
feeders regularly all the time we are
going and doing those inspections for
those here who don't know garbage
feeding of swine the term garbage
feeding doesn't mean feeding garbage
from your kitchen garbage or whatever uh
or from your local dumpster it means
feeding a certain type of food left over
from Human processes uh to swine
typically produce and and the term
garbage is defined not only federally
but here in the state
and um it's important to understand that
you cannot include meat products or any
kind of high-risk products for swine uh
to feed back to your your pigs that is a
high-risk um um pattern of behavior that
a lot of people do they just give all
their scraps to their pigs and it turns
out that that is one of the greatest
risk factors for African swine fever
classical swine fever foot and mouth
disease and some other diseases they're
always trying to creep into our nation
um so we do regulate and oversee garbage
feeding yeah quick question too um the
New Hampshire veterinary diagnostic
laboratory is in joint management with
UNH do they share the funding to fund
that uh facility uh their facility or
the programs yes and yes um they you
mean with the Department with our
department
yeah the commissioner might yeah it
there is I think the answer to that is
yes um there the funding for some of
their programs comes from some of the
same funding that our programs come from
I believe I I I can't give you a
complete answer on that maybe
commissioner Jasper I didn't hear the
question okay questions sorry it's not
um I might have to get back to you on
that okay
sorry um moving on so we just got a new
electronic data management system it's a
big deal in our division it's a $1.3
million project over four years we just
released we just had our starting uh
mandatory date for veterinarians to use
that starting on January 6th uh thank
you to those here who helped make that
possible uh we were doing just paperwork
and and and cabinets and lots of paper
records instead of electronic records so
now we can monitor dog and cap movements
and transfers electronically search make
reports it's much much easier and it's
also daunting we're now realizing the
number of cats and dogs that move in our
state and are transferred it's
exponentially more than any of us ever
thought um so uh moving on uh we
regulate the pet trade the pet trade is
is the elephant in the room that
commissioner Jasper was mentioning uh
it's it really is becoming a challenge
as we try to help dairy farms and pig
farms and animal livestock operations
and over 50% of our time is being taken
up by monitoring dog and cat Movement we
just don't have the staff it's important
work but we we do not have nearly the
staff and time to to do to do that
licensing program and oversight uh but
we do our best uh we work with equines
uh we try to oversee um
uh uh poultry operations because right
now Aven influenza is flying through uh
the state and the nation um our main
challenges are resources uh increase in
the number of small backyard Farms
compared to larger Farms there's a
consolidation of farms going west and we
have a lot of small backyard Farms which
are wonderful but they're harder to
manage harder to communicate with
sometimes and sometimes harder to find
um and then uh a lot of unmet needs
which we can talk about another time
aquaculture surds uh the garbage
Management program I mentioned uh small
backyard flocks would love a lot more
help from us and we would love to get
give them that we give them some um U
multiple opportunities for us to grow
and do agriculture related things um
instead of where sometimes our time ends
up being spent and the last page last
slide uh you're all very aware I'm sure
of the hpai highly pathogenic Avan
influenza outbreak that's happening for
the last 3 years across the poultry
industry 130 million Birds lost and the
industry is really struggling staggering
it has now jumped as of uh March of last
year into the dairy industry and is
affecting uh cows and high levels of
virus are being found in the milk the
milk is safe to drink it's pasteurized
uh raw milk is in question and um it has
now spread to 17 different states and
over a thousand dairy farms in the
United States so we spend for the last
three years a huge amount of our time
monitoring just this one virus and we
are very concerned about it
uh so it's not a small it's not a small
thing and there's a lot of potential for
it to get worse so we're starting our
own State milk um monitoring program
that Dr Crawford has launched and so
that we're going to start looking at
bulk tank and Silo milk and start just
making sure that uh the milk isn't in
our state uh that the no infected virus
or cattle are in our state uh so thank
you very much sorry for the going over
represent H Haskins had a question yes
thank you madam chair thank you Dr
Harvey could you share your contact
information with us yep absolutely Ely
um Dr Crawford's information is on the
front page here name and number and uh I
can certainly give you all my my card
and my my contact info our email is the
same it's always first name middle
initial and last we can send all of that
when we send the um presentation in to
Jamie too thank you uh represent
sakas hi um I appreciate very much what
you said about the transfer of dogs and
cats um I think that a lot of people
don't know
and they just pass pets around wherever
but the thing I was just curious about
are the
the import of animals from kill shelters
in the South because they come up like
on 93 or 95 and they um drop these
animals off at rest stops and um it just
seems like this huge black hole
amen thank you for saying that and there
is a massive massive pet trafficking
industry and I I that's my own word that
is Dr Nate Harvey's word that's not the
division's word but there is a massive
massive flow of pets going from the
south to the north we have a as far as
States go with their programs to monitor
intake paperwork and monitor paperwork
within the state we are pretty darn good
compared to some of the other states uh
but unfortunately that helps us to
reveal and see how many animals there
are I'm not saying that's wrong people
are trying to do the right thing and
help animals but a lot of them do not
want to be regulated they don't want to
be known about and they definitely don't
want to have to submit paperwork and ra
proof of rabies vaccinations and all the
things that protect public health so we
found it to be a difficult uh population
of people to work with sometimes but uh
we I think we're making good progress
but thank you for saying that that's
very uh Miner and then
Bixby thank you madam chairman doct uh
what what types of plans are in place to
uh mitigate
h5n1 um that is something we can we can
send you a whole email with some of the
things we've done within the state of
New Hampshire we're monitoring milk
we're communicating with dairy farms I
assume you mean h5n1 and dairy farms um
we've done extensive amount of work with
poultry and all the other states have
done extensive amount of work with ptry
but when it uh changed in April and
started infecting dairy cattle it became
something we've never seen before we've
never seen a virus with this level of
virus in the milk dairy count milk is
usually not a site for virus uh to
concentrate in so that's become a
problem
and so we're doing milk sampling we're
just starting it now in fact not only
are our milk inspectors in the
Department of Human Health and Human
Services trained to collect milk samples
and submit them for testing we just
jumped on board this past week and our
animal health technicians just got
trained and certified as milk inspectors
in case we end up with an emergency in
our state or anywhere in New England
where this shows up in even a single cow
in New England uh we're going to start
ramping up and potentially even uh test
down to the farm level or to the bulk
tank level right now we're doing over
large samples of silos that cover big
areas just to make sure we don't have it
at all in the state thank you
representative Bixby yeah so did I
understand you correctly that the the um
animal transfer database which is sort
of completely online like now uh has
really has helped
identify uh the the number of transfers
that we're failing to
track well no because because that it
has helped us to identify the number of
transfers of people that get the
appropriate paperwork which is
already exponentially more than we
thought because before we had paper
records that we couldn't even store
there was so such a volume now that it's
electronic and I can hit search how many
certificates we had we've already had
5,000 just about 4,840 certificates uh
just over the last few months in our
pilot program of this and some of our
veterinarians have not even signed on to
use it yet uh so um the the people who
are moving animals which is a vast
majority of people don't know that if
you're going to change the ownership of
your pet whether it means Give It Away
sell it Rescue It adopt it out by law in
New Hampshire you're supposed to provide
official health certificate or official
certificate of transfer for that animal
most people aren't doing that most
people think you can just sell a dog or
your give it to your
cousin I'm I don't even know how much it
will be if we don't uh follow the the
paperwork that's a great question
representative Bigby
representative Scully and then sopis we
have to kind of Move Along because uh
time is running through thank you
representative Scully well thank you
madam chair thank you doctor for being
here how is are these outbreaks actually
occurring is it animal trade between
states and when they say it BR it's in
17 States you know how does how does it
get that The quick summary is to look at
the two great question the two
differences between the two h5n1 viruses
we're dealing right now in the birds
it's in the Wildlife population and it
is in every most every many of the ducks
and birds and geese flying over our
farms and it's being showered across the
United States which is how 130 million
birds have been affected by this in the
dairy industry it was a mutation that
caused it to infect a cow and that
individual first index cow in Texas then
infected another cow and another cow and
some calves and the movement of cows
across the states is how that has spread
so it depends on the animal and the
virus you're talking about the milk one
is movement of cattle there's no
Wildlife Reservoir spreading this at all
this is strictly milk moving it direct
contact so it's an excellent question
because that matters our response yeah
thank you
sopus um one more question is um and I
might have old information but was that
virus then from the cow transmitted to a
human or was it from the birds to the
human the the the the new new uh stories
you're hearing this year of people being
infected with h5n1 virus those are
people being coming sick predominantly
from milk from cows from milking cows
and having raw milk splattered on a
small level in your eyes or in your
mouth or um there were a couple of very
very rare instances of it being
transmitted by birds to people but the
vast majority of the people you've heard
getting sick including the very sick
people that all came from milk from this
new outbreak in cattle that we're
thank you very much appreciate all the
provided good afternoon um for the
record my name is Josh Marshall and I'm
the assistant commissioner for the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food but to continue the chair's
metaphor I am pinch hitting for uh
Cheryl A our director of weights and
measures today who's at a National
Conference
um in uh South Carolina I believe I'm
going to be very brief because I'm not
the subject matter expert on here and we
have a really good distillation of the
overview of the division in the slides
but I did want to mention a couple of
things to sort of set the stage um you
know the Division of Weights and
measures serves the public to ensure
Equity prevails in the marketplace for
both consumers and businesses by
supporting and regulating Commerce that
is sold by a weight or a measure a
couple of examples of that would be the
deli scale at the supermarket which is
charging you a certain amount of money
for a certain weight of meat or the fuel
pump at the gas station which is
charging you for a certain amount of
liquid by volume and so we have a number
of inspectors that we send out to make
sure that uh all of those um are
licensed and certified and um just some
of the high level numbers the division
currently licenses 20,00 th000
commercial devices owned by more than
2,800
businesses now that doesn't mean that
we're our inspectors we have three
inspectors uh on staff it doesn't mean
that they're going out and touching each
of those devices each year because we
also um license 2117 service technicians
from private business who can also
inspect tests and certify those devices
uh we have sort of an audit program
Where It's Our intention to have
Department staff touch each device
within every five years so that we're
getting around to make sure that our
staff see and certify each device but
that's a the volume of devices is too
much for us to do each year there's over
a thousand way Masters who operate
vehicle scales that are used
commercially and uh the division itself
has eight full-time equivalents
including the director uh a program
specialist and program assistant who
support the administrative needs of the
licensing and certification programs and
Three Investigators uh along with the
state metrologist and a part-time State
met meterologist um I just also want to
point out that the inspectors and the
director are also uh certified through
the New Hampshire Police Academy as
part-time police officers which helps
with their ability to enforce um some of
these uh issues that might come up I'll
give you a quick example if you see the
big roadside sign at the uh gas station
says 299 a gallon you get to the pump
and as you're pumping the computer reads
329 that's uh out of compliance you
would report that to the division who
would send an inspector out there to see
what type of enforcement action should
be taken
um there's a lot more detail but I want
to get to the folks who um are subject
matter experts but I'm happy to try to
yeah so um in terms of uh what might be
um tested under scales would you uh
would your division uh test the scales
that are used by by farmers who are
selling at the farmers market or through
csas Etc absolutely and one of the um
one of the services sort of the Outreach
that's within some of the details of
these slides is we offer scale clinics
across the state I believe there's 10 of
them across the state usually in
coordination with a Cooperative
Extension field office and farmers can
bring up to three scales that are 30 PBS
or less and have those scales certified
for free so there's no charge they still
have to apply for the license which is
$18 if I recall uh after the last check
I paid um for my scales and um then they
can get the the certification done for
free any other questions thank you so
much
hello hello thank
you I AMG duie and I will sit and use
the microphone in just a moment I don't
want to overburden you with items but we
do a lot of Outreach and so in these
folders is a copy of what I'm going to
talk about today as well as some of the
Outreach material that put together
again
amling my director today here at Seager
her contact information is in that
folder um as well as on the copy that
you
received and I will begin with our
mission um so I'm an entomologist with
the Department our mission is to curtail
the spread of invasive insects plants
and pathogens that may neg atively
impact agriculture natural and human
ecosystems within the state of New
Hampshire we focus this on pests moved
by human
activities the core functions of our
division is to accomplish our mission
through lure inspection survey
certification quarantine and Outreach
activities for example the coasters that
you have in your folders have spotted
Lantern fly on them which is a pest we
are very concerned about it is close in
Massachusetts as close as North
chelsford and Fitchburg but we don't
know of any established populations in
New
Hampshire we have the Upland invasive
species coordinator who works with
invasive plant management throughout New
Hampshire the division takes the lead on
eradication of regulated pests when it's
warranted and then we're responsible for
honeybee Health we have fulltime five
full-time employees four of those are
entomologist IST s and one of them is an
is a botanist it's uh pretty nerdy over
in our office we have one part-time
employee and he is our apiary
inspector some of the activities that we
conduct are nursery and plant dealer
licensing we do a uh an inspection
program within the people that hold
those licenses we certify Nursery stock
and other plant products such as
firewood we issue compliance agreements
and permits for the movement of this
material we conduct exotic pest surveys
for federal that these are federally
funded um and they are for pests of
state and National concern we partner
with the USDA on permitting for
importation use and handling of foreign
soils biocontrol agents bacterial soil
amendments insects and other organisms
as authorized through the federal plant
protection act we have an Upland
invasive species program and Remediation
fund we survey map um and conduct
invasive plant control and Outreach the
apiary restriction sorry the apiary
registration program we have is
voluntary and we have an apiary
inspection program and those inspections
are conducted by the part-time employee
and then we identify insects of Public
public concern um arrod identification
usually consists of spiders or ticks
things people are concerned about around
their house and things like that the
next slide are our primary laws and
rules I won't spend too much time here
but I would just want to point out that
we just recently reviewed and revamped
our beekeeping And Hive products rules
and two of our major rules are up for um
they expire in 2027 and that's the
nursery plant dealers and Nursery stock
rules as well of as our invasives um and
so we're going to be looking a lot
closer at them in the next pium I wanted
to note that we as of 2024 we had 990
licensed plant dealers in New Hampshire
and then we are up to 701 registered
Apiaries wow wow some notable
quarantines that I wanted to mention are
the firewood quarantine this is New
Hampshire specific and protects New
Hampshire by prohibiting the importation
of untreated firewood there are
exceptions to this as allowed by
compliance agreements which our
inspectors um take care of spongy moth
formerly known as gypsy moth is a
federally regulated uh sorry it's a
federally regulated Pest and New
Hampshire is within this federally
regulated area shippers or producers
within New Hampshire that are sending
regulated articles outside of this
quarantine area must be under a
compliance agreement um or have an
inspection Japanese beetle European corn
or onion white rot and a few others are
pests that we've dealt with here in New
Hampshire for maybe decades but not
every state in the nation has them there
are particular states that have
regulations specific to those pests and
we assist New Hampshire producers to
meeting those plant protection
requirements of the receiving States
most of the time um that does vary by
state by the good or the plant product
that they want to ship the production
and storage conditions as well as
sometimes the point of origin of the
plant material this usually requires
certification and
inspection um I want to point out that
in 2024 we conducted pest detection
surveys for 33 pest threats to New
Hampshire and the nation these surveys
were conducted at nurseries Vegetable
Farms roadside locations forested areas
that are identified as high risk in 2025
we have 35 pests on the list that we are
going to be surveying for at similar
locations a couple of the challenges I
can point out real quick are that the
distribution cost of one of our
full-time employees is across multiple
accounting units um and multiple federal
grants this state system that we
currently use does not accommodate this
and it does require a number of
additional man hours to ensure correct
budgeting the second is supporting
online vendors shipping plants out of
state e-commerce is is a concern
Nationwide and my boss is probably
talking about it right now at the
meeting she is at um this is a
non-traditional type of clientele that
may have needs such as those regulatory
requirements that are not being met by
our current
system and the third challenge I'd like
to talk about is the information
management and accessibility across of
our across all of our programs licenses
inspection and survey and we can end
with this one because it's ending on a
positive note we have just uh
implemented or are starting to implement
the LCP system with Trace first
University and this is hopefully going
to allow us to do everything online
manage things a little bit better and
it's very exciting for our staff to be
able to like actually join the 21st
century and lastly I wanted to talk
about a couple of the Innovative
programs that our division partakes in
NH bugs. org is an excellent online
resource for New Hampshire residents
resents as well as visitors to the state
it's a collaboration between the
division of plant industry the division
of forest and lands within natural and
cultural resources UNH Cooperative
Extension USDA apys which is the animal
plant health inspection service as well
as the USDA Forest Service this is a
streamline this program or the website
allows for a streamline response for
Pest detections and public reports we
rely heavily on the public to report
things such as spotted Lantern fly which
is why we've developed coasters so that
people now know just another way for us
to reach people um and this NH bugs. org
has a strong collaborative effort it's
um we kind of like to view it as a
clearing house where all those
departments that are working can put the
information in one stop in one place for
One-Stop shopping for the residents
firewood scout.org is about recreational
transportation of firewood risks um
firewood is the number one pathway for
the spread of invasive pest we joined
firewood Scout a few years ago this is
uh provides Outreach for proactive steps
that campers can take to protect New
Hampshire forests it's an online mapping
platform that allows visitors to look up
where firewood is going to be for sale
near the location that they're camping
all they have to do is type in the the
zip code of where they're going to be
staying and it pops up a list of the
vendors in New Hampshire in that that
area within a certain radius New
Hampshire is one of 13 states taking
partaking in this program and we have in
New Hampshire alone over 500 firewood
vendors listed lastly is a systems
approach to Nursery certification this
is called sank this promotes a
harmonized risk-based systems approach
to Nursery and Greenhouse production
it's a voluntary certification program
that was developed by the national plant
board which my boss is a part of um as
well as along with American Hort we have
one sank facility in New Hampshire and
this is actually the only facility
Nationwide that is duy enrolled in both
the sank program as well as the US
Canadian Greenhouse certification
program I will do my best to answer any
questions you may have representative
Bixby yeah so I not one thing I didn't
see on this or here you mentioned was
the EM Emerald emerald ash borer uh
which was um
pretty a pretty big bit of news maybe a
decade or so ago yes and I was wondering
whether that's because it's under
control or because we've lost our ash
trees
or the answer is a little bit of all of
that I will say that uh I received my my
position was filled because Emerald
ashor was found in New Hampshire so I
feel like I should get that tattooed on
me somewhere but um Emerald nbor is now
considered widespread in New Hampshire
but it is not Nationwide and so we do
have to be careful about moving stuff
out of our state the division of forest
and lands um in the the forest and lands
division is um they are responsible for
the biocont control efforts and the
monitoring of Ash currently since it's
not really a regulatory issue anymore
the division of plant industry has sort
of stepped
back so you were working on on wasps
that were bio controlled do you know if
that's that's been working or if that's
yes so we have released three different
small Paras toy to parasitic wasps in
New Hampshire all of this information
just went out in the 2024 summary
developed by the division of forest and
lands I believe you can find that on
their website and I'm happy to find to
share it um when we send you all the
information that you've requested after
this meeting but it's fascinating what
they've been able to do these are
non-stinging wasps they parasitize a
life stage of the emerald ash for and
we're currently releasing them in
multiple locations throughout the state
in Ash stands that was Master project I
was so my Master's project was on a
large predatory wasp that was used as
a kind of monitoring a biom monitoring
program and Peter's wife Jessica bulker
was one of my advisers which is how we
know each other yes it was fun playing
with wasps for a couple of
Summers very charismatic thank you
appreciate all your information you're
good afternoon I'll be extremely brief
uh it's it is my name is Al W and I am
the division director of regulatory
services for the Department of
Agriculture it is nice to see friendly
and in recognizable faces and it's
exciting to see some new faces it's a
great committee um as as commissioner
said initially if you have questions
when you are looking at lsrs and so
forth give them a call and if it
involves any of us in the division we'd
love to assist you I mean it's it's
worked great there's a lot of
legislation that comes through that that
requires I believe uh clarification as
to how we might Implement those or or
the potential impacts associated with
implementation so that's of all like
taking Dave's lead of all the things I
want do is emphasize that relative to
what we do as a division if you were
have srel down to the end of it what we
really do it's it's it's it's human
health and safety I mean it's labeling
it's
inspections uh the whole point and
purpose for that is so at the end of the
day um we have a handle on what's being
distributed throughout the state and if
we have recalls that are necessary we
can jump on those right but it's
critical that the that labeling be be
correct uh for that purpose so we go out
we'll do inspections relative to uh to
assuring that we can we can do that we
also deal um now we deal in in three
primary um we exist in really in three
ways we do we represent a lot of of of
federal law and our inspectors are
uh issued the authority by federal
government to do certain inspections
associated with the uh growth of of
vegetables right uh the point being
the proper
handling growth and handling of the
material before it gets to Consumers is
critical because of some of these
pathogens that pass on with the
vegetables so we'll go out and we'll do
inspections to assure that the handling
is proper such that we don't end up with
an outbreak to begin with that we then
have to go back and Trace right um so
there's a lot of components to that a
lot of pieces um a second one is we work
on the National level with organizations
that will develop uh example laws and
rules for consideration by each state
Across the Nation so that manufacturers
only have to produce to one set of of of
requirements and in that we have
toxicologists uh professors
manufacturing experts control officials
from every state get we get together we
use S uh really good scientific basis to
to to make recommendations to you guys
as as to what might might be appropriate
and in the case coming forward you'll
see something associated with bio
stimulants um
uh recently there was some changes to
fertilizer these are all things you're
going to look at you may interact with
us to ask questions associated with that
um we do pet food and there is a
component in Pet Food associated with
sampling it's not just labeling and in
assuring that we can backtrack but when
a when a registration comes in it
identifies what the con uh contents of
that pet food is and we have an expert
who just looks through that day in and
day out and and and is looking for
ingredients in in that pet food that
could be harmful um and typically when
we run into those issues it's it's it's
not the larger companies because they
have Experts of their own that they can
hire It's usually the smaller companies
it's usually people within New Hampshire
who are who are producing wanting to
sell that they may not have that
technical expertise so we'll step in
after a review and we we'll call them so
here's our concern we can't register
this product we can't allow you to sell
it for these reasons and we everything
we do we try to work with everybody to
the best of our ability to get them to
be able to sell their product our
objective is not to stop anybody it's
it's human health and safety um it's
also pet safety
so I don't know I'm really encouraged by
that because I I I get good feedback
that that my staff is great um
and helpful in in that aspect we also
deal with specific rsas that were driven
not by national not by federal but by
the citizenry of the State of New
Hampshire and that includes um things
like local local marketing somebody
spoke about agricultural land and
protecting agricultural land we have an
Alp Pro uh program where if it's
properly funded we uh have the
capability of going out and
purchasing the rights to land in
perpetuity for the purpose of
Agriculture I mean in my opinion the
only way you're going to save a
agriculture is by setting that land in
perpetuity for that purpose because
nobody no government entity has the
right to come in and say you can't sell
your land right it's a really important
for for people who feel that uh
preservation of agriculture in the state
of New Hampshire is important that's an
important program but has to be funded
um we do thanks and we we we also work a
lot with uh New Hampshire um extension
over at UNH great program I I agree with
everybody we we have we work C and glove
uh on a on a couple of different
programs the the registration of
uninspected rabbits and poultry for
instance uh Lumber grading there's a lot
of people in New Hampshire make their
own Lumber and build with it so you have
to have an expert who's capable of
looking at that saying yeah that's safe
right um the Seal of uh quality program
great program where staff will go out
and you know you have fsma you have Gap
you have those are federal and you have
New Hampshire seal of quality where our
staff will go out and and even take a
step above and do inspections and and
expectations in the way product is
produced grown and produced and
presented in such a manner that it is of
a very high quality and once they pass
that and it's a yearly inspection we
have to document everything as as they
can use that sticker on their product
seal of quality um there's 14 programs
that fall under my Division I can I
can't get into the detail associated
with with all of them but your your
packet here uh it does a good job of of
at least presenting what they are and if
you go on to our website I think you'll
you'll find uh really good descriptions
of what each one of those uh programs
are the last thing I'd like to say and
and I'd like
to representative bigs
spoke to this earlier in that we have in
this division been going through our
laws and really modernizing and taking
out laws that mandat things that we're
supposed to do that we simply can't do
or that just don't make sense anymore
and I think last time we got rid of
something like 40 paragraphs it was it
was great it's I thankful for it because
now I'm not being pushed to do things
like look for bone and coal for instance
right I mean silly thing but when the
law says shall there's a consideration
there that I have to take um you'll see
some things coming I I mentioned it bio
stimulant Trace first is our
registration monetization program that's
going across the whole department I
can't say enough about that we've been
living in the 80s relative to how we
deal with paperwork that's my my opinion
this will bring things in into uh into
the current so that we can start to
really get a grip on what we're doing
how we're doing it I mean that was a
question we had earlier how do we what
are the metrics right well well once we
have these programs in place it's going
to be a lot easier to figure out what
those metrics might be um uh we just had
a recently we had fertilizer requirement
for for signage that we've put into
place we're we're doing an educational
program right now we're going to every
hardware store that we know of that
sells fertilizer and we're presenting
them the information because all of a
sudden as January 1 this stuff has to be
done Nobody Knows It exists it's not my
intent to go out and penalize people for
not doing something like that we need to
have an educational piece and that's
what we're doing um we're going to be
modernizing egg rules apple cider just
change Horticultural growing um again
it's all right here in the packet I
appreciate your time thank
you representative Bixby yeah so just uh
clarification is the trace first program
is that the uh the database that um that
we passed last year in the budget to
provide uh basically to uh be able to do
on computers what people were hand
entering before absolutely okay yeah
it's a pleasure thank you any other
questions from the committee and thank
you so much for this presentation uh for
all you uh uh division heads and area
heads uh lot of really good information
for our committee thank
you i' just like to um reiterate
something that uh director Ryman said
which is that uh the fol in uh the
department are really fantastic with
working with people on legislation and
figuring out how to get things right uh
I I don't know how many times I have had
I've been working on a bill and I'm not
quite sure how something should work in
the statutes and I go to the appropriate
division head or I go to direct
commissioner Jasper and say how did this
work and they give me great explanations
and really put things in context so that
we can make better legislation yeah
thank you
if if I could thank you for your time
and please you have some of our cards
you certainly all have mine again please
come by uh give me a call first I'm
usually in the office but tomorrow I'm
in Vermont so um if you have questions
call me stop by um we are here to serve
the people of New Hampshire uh and
probably a little more directly the
legislature as well and we do look
forward to working with you and we
appreciate the opportunity to be here
thank you thank you very
much okay
um I guess you guys uh maybe take a a
two-minute break and uh then uh our
department of Dees will be coming in and
thank you for your patience uh Dees
we'll be underway shortly just taken a
break okay yeah yeah sure yeah oh yeah
yeah sure
curent
okay yeah we're we're still waiting for
two people and then we'll get started
waiting on
um yeah all right
um
yeah thank you so much for coming in I'm
sorry that we're running late I
appreciate your time and um I introduce
you director whimet welcome to
environment and agriculture thank you
Madame chair and members of the
committee uh again for the record my
name is Mike whimet I serve as director
of the waste management division um and
I'm joined here by our assistant
director Sarah uas Kern and Sarah and I
are going to be sharing the presentation
role uh today but I have with me our
whole team of five Bureau administrators
who will introduce in turn as we talk
about each of the bureaus and their work
and also want to acknowledge and
introduce Amy smagula from our Water
Division who is the invasive species
expert at Dees and at the request of the
chair um we've asked Amy to come along
and following our presentation she's
going to have a brief presentation on
aquatic invasive species that uh she'll
share with you so we appreciate Amy
being here and we're always happy to
work with our Water Division um so we
appreciate the opportunity to be before
you today um we really we recognize
there's a lot we do and you've heard a
lot probably already today and there's a
lot we could share so we've given you a
presentation it's pretty thorough it
gives you several slides dedicated to
each Bureau um but we're not going to
talk to each one of those components of
those slides we're going to go a little
more highflying so we can we're going to
shoot for probably Sarah and I
completing our presentation in about 30
minutes and then I think Amy might have
five or 10 minutes she'd like to present
to you on invasive species and then of
course we're at your pleasure we'll be
happy to entertain any questions great
thank you so much so with that um the
first slide our senior management team I
think many of you know but perhaps not
all of you um our commissioner is Bob
Scott our assistant commissioner is Adam
kpo and then um Susan Carl Carlson is
our chief operations officer and then uh
I serve as director of the waste
division Craig Wright is director of our
air Resources Division and rainy peler
is our Water Division
director next slide
so then our division is uh essentially
comprised of five bureaus and um this
graphic here gives you an idea of the
overarching sort of categories of
responsibilities that each Bureau um
covers um we're going to be talking
about those in some detail uh in as as
we talk about the individual
bureaus and so um but if we look for
stay high level for just a moment about
the whole sort of division's uh goals
and responsibilities are primary
responsibility is really about
protection of Public Health in the
environment that's in in virtually all
the statutory uh Provisions that apply
to our division and um we do that um
through a combination of really trying
to avoid and prevent releases of
contaminants and materials that can harm
human health the environment um and that
includes we we accomplished that
specifically for petroleum products
hazardous waste and solid waste um and
we try to do that through public
Outreach through technical assistance
and training of the regul community and
we you'll hear today about a number of
formalized training programs that we
provide for some of our regulated
parties and we also uh when when we
aren't so successful in preventing those
releases uh we have a response program
and then a remediation programs that
help to address the impacts of any
releases and contaminants so we do
provide um 247 365 day per year uh
response capability for response to O
oil and hazardous materials incidents
that same group group of responders also
uh routinely responds to Citizen compl
and investigates citizen complaints um
we have uh they also engage in response
uh preparedness planning both Inland on
the Inland Waters with respect to
potential oil spills as well as on the
Sea Coast region and then um we do put a
lot of work into contaminated site
investigation remediation and Mitigation
Of contaminated drinking water and you
hear about some examples of those as we
talk about each of the bureaus so with
that um I want to turn it over to Sarah
to talk about um our first Bureau which
is oil remediation and compliance
Bureau thank you the oil remediation and
compliance Bureau is a team of
hydrogeologists Engineers and
environmental scientists that is headed
up by their administrator Bob bishop and
Bob is here
today and the purpose of this Bureau is
to deal with the problem of pollution
from petroleum releases and we'll get
into a little bit of how they do that
but what it boils down to is making sure
that petroleum that is stored in the
state stays where it belongs that it
stays in the tank systems that it's in
making sure if a spill happens that it
gets cleaned up quickly and
effectively for petroleum contamination
that is lingering in the environment
making sure that the appropriate
Technologies are applied to get it
cleaned up and that it is monitored and
the health risks uh potential health
health risks associated with it are
mitigated and then providing assistance
for funding for the cleanups of these
releases which can be
costly the first section that we will
talk about is the oil compliance section
and as you can see on this slide between
the underground storage tanks and above
ground storage tanks storing Petroleum
in the state at any given time there's
about 200 million gallons of petroleum
being
stored so uh what the oil compliance
section does is it works to eliminate
the possibility of spills by carefully
permitting engineered storage
systems by educating the folks who
operate those storage systems to make
sure that they're maintained properly so
that releases don't occur and by
conducting regular inspections so that
we can identify conditions that might
allow a
release our oil compliance section is
authorized to regulate petroleum and
hazardous substance storage in
underground storage tanks petroleum
storage in above ground storage tanks
but in both those cases uh an exception
is Residential Heating Oil like what you
may have at your house is not regulated
program the oil compliance section
reviews uh for underground storage tanks
about 50 designs per year to see if
they're compliant with the rules for
storage tank systems um and they inspect
after the approval of a of a plan and
design to be sure that the system is
constructed in accordance with the
design now these designs can be either
for new facilities or for existing
facilities that are being
modified and they also conduct
inspections of underground storage
facilities once every 3 years for each
facility for above ground storage tanks
we see about 25 designs per year that we
review both for new and modified systems
and uh historically the above ground
storage tank systems were inspected when
there was a problem expect that we
thought might be there or when there was
a complaint what we're working to do now
is to develop a program where those
above ground storage systems are
inspected on a regular basis as well as
systems when the oil doesn't stay where
it should that's when we get into spill
response in our oil remediation and
compliance Bureau we call it or RCB we
have the spill response and complaint
investigation section like director
whims mentioned this group is on call 24
hours a day 7 days a week during all
holidays to respond to releases of
petroleum and other Haz hazardous sub
substances that occur and these folks
have extensive training so that they're
able to manage hazardous material
emergencies in the most protective and
effective way to protect human health
and environmental
resources they respond to approximately
300 spills per year in the state and
about 90% of those spills involve
petroleum um I say involve petroleum
because it might be petroleum as well as
another hazardous
substance you saw in a previous slide
that there's approximately
156 million gallons of oil stored in
above ground storage tanks in the state
and most of that storage is on the coast
of New Hampshire right there near Great
Bay so our spill response folks have uh
created extensive plans for protecting
the resources like in Great Bay if there
is a large scale oil
spill and they also uh conduct regular
drills of those plans to respond to
coast another duty of this section is
that they investigate complaints of
mismanagement of
petroleum um hazardous materials and
solid waste throughout the state so we
keep those folks
busy another section of or RCB is the
petroleum remediation section this group
focuses on mitigating the long-term
impacts of petroleum releases um many of
the sites that are being cleaned up or
monitored by the petroleum remediation
section
have been around a long time um many of
the releases occurred before the
regulations for storage of oil that oil
compliance overseas were as robust as
they are now and the goal of the
petroleum remediation section where
there's contamination is to return
groundwater quality to meet drinking
water standards and to mitigate the
potential impacts to human health from
petroleum contamination in the
groundwater to tect people to mitigate
um petroleum contaminated drinking water
supplies and uh to mitigate indoor air
problems when a petroleum spill occurs
close to a building and it impacts the
indoor
air and the the last section in or RCB
that I'd like to talk about is the fund
management section as you can imagine
the cost of these cleanups that we're
discussing can be very high so high that
um even companies with resources have a
hard time getting the cleanups done in a
timely fashion unless they have some
assistance the oil discharge and
Disposal cleanup fund was set up by RSA
146d and that uh reimburses for costs to
clean up petroleum contamination at
eligible
sites in addition to assisting with the
economic impacts associated with
petroleum contamination this fund
satisfies a federal requirement that
facilities like gas stations need to
have Financial Assurance many of these
facilities would find it hard to find
High Enough insurance coverage or too
expensive to obtain that insurance
coverage and this fund serves to fulfill
that Federal
requirement the fund management section
administers the oil oil discharge and
Disposal fund on behalf of the oil
discharge and Disposal fund dispersement
board um and that board consists of
folks who are appointed by the
governor um the board approves the use
of the fund for cleanup purposes for oil
and spill response purposes including um
it has authorized what we call the safe
tank program which is a program that
assists lowincome homeowners in New
Hampshire with replacing their home
heating oil tanks that are failing or
about ready ready to fail and in that
way the fund helps prevent many releases
of heating oil that would otherwise
year that concludes the discussion of
the oil remediation and compliance
Bureau and next I'd like to talk about
the Hazardous Waste remediation Bureau
which has some similarities to the oil
remediation compliance Bureau but this
group focuses on overseeing
investigation and cleanup of regulated
contaminants that are not related to
petroleum
and it's a group of hydrogeologists and
Engineers that are headed up by Jeff
Marts the bureau administrator who's
right here thanks
Jeff the Hazardous Waste remediation
Bureau is uh divided into two sections
the state sites section and the
federally LED sites section we'll talk
about State sites first uh that group is
further divided into the emerging
contaminants program the brownfields
program program and the groundwater
remediation and permitting program and
collectively these subsections are
responsible for regulatory oversight of
hazardous waist sites monitor monitoring
of closed unlined landfills monitoring
of active Solid Waste
landfills um release detection
permitting and also for work at
Brownfield
sites the brownfields program helps to
revitalize
underutilized contaminated Andor
abandoned properties in the state by
helping to bring them back into active
reuse the folks in this program work
with uh Federal funding and help
communities to investigate and clean up
sites in their towns so that they can
make better use of those properties this
uh slide here summarizes some of the
work of the brownfields program that's
going on right now oh the brownfields
program also administers what's called a
covenant not to sue program and that's a
program that incentivizes cleanups of
these old sites by providing some
liability protections for the folks who
are taking on the
projects the uh so we had the state
sites programs and we also have the
federal sites programs Federal sites
come in in two types the super fund
sites and the Department of Defense
sites
the Superfund group is part of a state
and federal partnership that helps to
clean up super fund sites super fund
sites fall into two groups there are
ones that have a potentially responsible
party leading the cleanup and there are
ones where there's not a viable
potentially responsible party and those
are called fund Le sites the slide here
summarizes those
sites and then the department of a
defense sites group uh IT addresses a
range of sites everything from um
formerly used defense sites like uh Old
Musket drill yards dating back to the
Revolutionary War on the all the way up
to Major more modern complex remediation
projects like the trees trade the peas
trade Port where contamination from P
from firefighting foam releases impacted
two major public water supply
walls they work very closely with
branches of the Department of Defense uh
like the Air Force and Army Corps to
investigate and Remediation remediate
activities and now we'll move on to the
mtbe remediation
Bureau thank you Sarah so uh the MTB
remediation Bureau is uh it's I guess
it's coming on 10 years old now but it
uh it's the newest of our bureaus it was
created um as a result of the um
lawsuits that were brought regarding uh
the impacts of mtbe on groundwater and
drinking water in the state and that
Bureau is headed up by Matt Taylor who's
here today um and it's staffed with
engineers hydrogeologists and Grant and
Loan Specialists um it's a really a
bureau that we provide a tremendous
amount of financial assistance and
technical assistance to the communities
um the MTB settlement fund was or the
MTB case was really broken into two
sections there was a settling parties
the the state filed suit I think going
back to like 2003 or four um against uh
a number of uh manufacturers and
Distributors of gasoline and all of
those uh parties to the suit except for
Exxon Mobile settled and there was about
$80 million that was gained in that
settlement and that forms the MTB
settlement fund which has been used over
the last 10 years for providing uh
direct work at UH in communities where
MTB contaminations had an outsized
impact on drinking water quality we've
used it to remove uh um underground
tanks that that may still be posing a
risk because of their age and still have
MTV gasoline in them and also providing
spill prevention at scrapyards that
manage those uh those old vehicles um
and then the the Exxon Mobile went to
trial they were not a settling party and
the state went to trial
back in 2014 and got a verdict um that
amounted to after everything was all
sugared off uh approximately uh $300
million or I think about $280 million
that went to uh established the drinking
water and groundwater trust fund which
was created by the by the legislature uh
for that purpose and it has a broader
scope than just addressing MTB
contamination it's been used over time
under the direction of of a drinking
water um and groundwater trust fund
advisory commission to provide
assistance to communities for improving
drinking water systems and we'll we'll
talk a little bit about uh specifics of
what that's done and then lastly we have
a past response fund um which was also
established by the legislature to
provide loans grants and assistance to
communities and and individuals who've
been impacted by past
contamination so if we go to the
settlement fund uh important to know not
that around 45% of the population in the
state gets their water from a private
drinking water well and um so we have
very robust sampling program that we run
out of the MTB remediation Bureau and
we've uh sampled over 19,000 residential
Wells since its Inception we do about
2,000 per year that's turned out to be
particularly helpful in the case of our
pasas efforts um we also again as I
mentioned do abandoned us removals spill
prevention assistance
and provide alternate water in mtbe
impacted communities and that program
has been responsible for projects that
have installed more than 20 miles of new
waterline U piping to provide safe clean
drinking water to people who have been
impacted by in communities who've been
impacted by mtbe
contamination the drinking water and
groundwater trust fund again came from
the Exxon Mobile portion of the of the
of the lawsuit and that has been used to
great effect since its Inception um to
provide assistance for construction
loans and grants to improve the
infrastructure of public drinking water
in the state and and dozens of
communities provides grants for
protecting Source waters for for Public
Water Systems uh it's also partnered we
partnered with the Water Division to
provide assistance for lead Remediation
in schools grants for schools to cover
100% of the cost to remove their lead
fixtures um and outlets and then also
some grants for uh Prov for the
that Public Water Systems might want to
study whether a small public water
system wants to combine with another
public water system and that might
actually be more cost effective and long
be a better long-term plan than making
specific Capital Improvements to their
particular water system and then we also
have a private well initiative which I
mentioned where we do sample a lot of
wells for for
pasas um the MTB remediation Bureau um
past response fund essentially uh provid
Ides uh assistance for loans and grants
to communities to address past
contamination in drinking water um and
also uh operates a very robust pfast
rebate program where we provided over
4,400 rebates to Residents totaling over
$6 million to put treatment on their
individual private Wells to address past
contamination or if they're fortunate
enough to be located near a public water
system to connect to the local public
water system and that um basically
program provides up to $5,000 to offset
the cost of putting a treatment system
in your home or up to $10,000 to offset
the cost of connection connecting to a
public water system and then uh funds
from that fund have also been used to
support a very successful um aquous
Fighter fighting foam takeback program
that we ran this past year where we
collected over 11,000 gallons of legacy
firefighting Foams that contain high
levels of pasas from our Municipal and
local fire departments and we um
collected that material and trucked it
off to a facility in Ohio that over the
course of the next several months will
be treating that to destroy the pasas
Foams so that uh describes uh in a
nutshell sort of what's been going on in
our MTB remediation Bureau um next I
want to talk about our Solid Waste
Management Bureau and that's headed up
by leam McKenna who our administrator
and Le is here today um again that's
staffed with engineers and environmental
scientists and planners and we cover um
a variety of of activities related to
managing Solid Waste safely that
includes an engineering and permitting
section which reviews applications for
new facility permits and modifications
to those permits and reviews reports
submitted by both closed and active
landfills uh they provide technical
assistance to applicants and permites
and and enforce the terms of the permits
that are issued we have a compliance
Assurance section which inspects
facilities and reviews um most of the
non- landfill related uh facility
reports and they engage in compliance
enforcement activities to make sure that
the rules are being complied with and
also they head up our rul making
activities and then there's a reporting
information and financial management
section which is responsible for the
intake and process processing of almost
all of the documentation that comes into
the bureau uh they manage our financial
assurance and grants Management Programs
uh for closed landfills and
incinerators and then lastly we have a
materials management and education and
planning section and that section trains
and certifies over, 1600 operators
working at Solid Waste facilities in New
Hampshire uh we provide Outreach to
municipalities looking for information
about waste diversion and they also
responsible for drafting Solid Waste
management plans and reports that are
required uh by by Statute for us to
produce um they'll also be working this
year on rules to create a program to
carry out the food waste disposal ban
that was implemented by the legislature
last
year so there's a slide there that kind
of describes Solid Waste suffice to say
pretty much anything that isn't a
hazardous waste is a solid waste with
the exception of uh things like yard
waste or um waste or wastewater
treatment sludge which is largely
Division the we regulate approximately
200 uh operating facilities um those
include transfer stations and recycling
centers and processing and treatment
facilities which could include a waste
of energy facility or compost a food
composting facility we also regulate um
landfills that take Municipal Solid
Waste bulky waste Ash and construction
and demolition debris and um we have
about 150 auto recycling centers that we
regulate and then we have a legacy of
about 300 primarily unlined inactive
closed landfills that were largely owned
by municipalities that were owned and
operated during the uh early part of the
1900s all the way through to about the
early 1980s before we moved primarily to
lined facilities for management of
waste um so we have uh nine operating
landfills currently and three of them
are specific to certain waste types and
six are for MSW facilities um the
specific waste types include the eping
bulky waste facility the cornhill road
facility in bosin which takes cndd
debris and the marac coash landfill at
the uh power
station so we administer this program
through a series of permits so any of
these facilities requires a permit so
that is a the primary function of our um
engineering and permitting
section so with with that I want to go
to uh our last Bureau that we're going
to talk about and that's our hazardous
waste management Bureau and that's
headed up by Todd pescovitz who's also
here with us today um and that is
staffed with chemists environmental
scientists and Engineers um who are
responsible for implementing um the
federal resource conservation Recovery
Act or what we call recro for short and
that was the law that was passed in 1980
to estab excuse me 1976 to establish a
cradle degrade management system for
managing hazard waste in the state and
we provide uh we've been authorized to
implement that for many years and we do
a lot of work to maintain that
authorization that authorization means
that once you have an authorized program
that's been approved by EPA and the
Ricker
program the state rules become the law
of the land and the federal rules cease
to exist so it's very important that we
maintain that authorization and maintain
a robust program because the state laws
the law of the land in New Hampshire
when it comes to management of hazardous
waste um The Bureau is responsible for
implementing the program and the state
receives a grant um funds to that help
to support that work um it consists of
various sections that oversee compliance
technical support managing and tracking
of data and Technical Support to the
regulated community so we'll talk a
little bit about each one of those
sections so our authorization section as
I said it's very important that we
maintain our authorization and um we do
we really kind of work full-time on that
because the federal government is
constantly amending and changing those
rules and we need to pay attention to
that and adopt those changes as they
become effective at the federal level um
so that's really a constant work product
that we have to keep working on and
we're always working on on rulemaking
and maintaining our authorization under
the program uh the hazard space Bureau
also has a technical assistance section
and that includes some very important
work that is involves training um and
self-certification so for generators of
waste of more than 220 pounds per month
what we would call a full quantity
generator they're required to have on
staff a h a trained certified Hazard was
coordinator that has gone through a
training and certific certification
program that's administered by the
department and so we spend we have staff
that are dedicated to providing that
training on an ongoing basis they have a
basic training and then a variety of
more advanced modules to help keep those
folks really U trained in an expert
level to safely manage hazardous waste
at their companies and then um we have a
uh small quantity gener compliance
certification program there are far more
small quantity generators than large
quantity generators it would be very
difficult for us to train all of those
people or to to inspect them with any
great regularity so what we developed
veloped a number of years ago is a
certification program where they
basically are required to do a self-
audit every 3 years self- certify their
compliance and report that to the agency
we review those reports and then if
there's anything that raises a flag we
use that to identify where we might go
and conduct uh focused and targeted
inspections and that's proved to really
significantly improve the compliance of
our small quantity generators and I
would note I I began my career working
in that in that Bureau and one of the
things that became very evident to me
quickly is that in fact many of the
hazardous waste sites that created
significant groundwater problems and POS
significant risk to communities were
actually created by small quantity
generators who had mismanaged their
waste you might think it would be the
larger generators that that would
predominantly cause those problems and
they and they certainly did their share
but in many cases those facilities are
are better staffed and better resourced
and they were able to manage their way
safely and in many cases the small
quantity General ators were smaller
businesses that didn't really have a lot
of resources to put to it weren't always
all that well educated about how to um
manage waste properly and so this small
quantity generator self-certification
program has really helped them to get
very cost effectively and efficiently to
understand what does they need to do to
manage their waste safely and it's
really made huge improvements in
prevention of of waste sites we also
have a technical assistance section
which provides household hazardous waste
grants to IP alties to collect household
waste and also a pollution prevention
program which provides free confidential
technical assistance and compliance
assistance um to any companies who ask
for it and helps them reduce their waste
and use less toxic products and then we
have a permitting section we do have a
number of facilities that we don't have
any um permited treatment storage or
disposal facilities that operate
commercially in the state um all the
waste that's generated here that has to
go to a licensed facility is actually
shipped out of state um but we do have a
number of manufacturing facilities that
may generate hazardous wastewaters that
are subject to regulation and in many
cases they treat those wastewaters on
site to um to render them non-hazardous
and and appropriate for disposal in the
local sewage systems and we permit those
with limited permits to make sure that
those treatment systems being permit are
being operated correctly and
safely and then the compliance section
um is where you know we really kind of
rubber meets the to make sure that folks
are complying we have an inspection
program that um inspects facilities we
in the in FY 2023 plan was you know we
inspected 16 large quantity generators
and 16 others um and then also to the
extent we get citizen complaints that
may spawn an additional inspection at
another facility and then we have an
enforcement program that um ensures fair
and consistent application of those
rules and a US program that Focus
specifically on how used oils are
managed in the
state and the facts are that we have
about 10 a. half million pounds of waste
generated in the state and over 20
almost 2200 regulated facilities and
about almost 300 of those are those
larger quantity facilities that I
mentioned but 1,00 of them are those
small quantity generators that are
subject to self-certification and with
that we've taken a whirlwind tour of uh
of our division and uh I I don't know
how you want it we could take questions
now or I could turn it over to Amy to
present on the invasive species and then
we can come back and field questions for
as long as you'd
like let's have Amy come up and then
afterwards we'll have
uh have questions for the entire
department terrific thank you thank you
so
much thank you madam chair and committee
members my name is Amy smagula and I'm a
chief aquatic biologist at the
Department of Environmental Services is
I I also uh direct our lony Center which
is where we look at lakes ponds rivers
in the state so we're going to take a
quick dive into water for a few minutes
while I update you on the invasive
species program so we focus mostly on
aquatic invasive plants at the
Department of Environmental Services but
we also do work with aquatic invasive
animals because they are out there and I
just wanted to give you an in
introduction and overview of the issue
and sort of a state of the state for
what we're seeing across New Hampshire
today and how we as an agency and as a
state have been dealing with aquatic
invasive species for the last number of
years uh I'm very familiar with the
program I coordinated it for 26 years
before switching into my current
position so I've seen a lot of different
issues that have Arisen across the state
and the definition for an invasive
species federally dates back back to
1999 and it includes a species that's
not native to a particular area so it
doesn't really belong here and the real
concern is that these things come into
our state our Lakes our rivers and they
cause economic and environmental harm
and harm to human health and those are
the reasons why we are concerned about
those they have a lot of characteristics
that cause them to spread quickly uh
jump between water bodies and they lack
natural predators and they have a lot of
impacts on our natural resources they
can uh threaten native species including
rare threatened and endangered species
that we have in our state they are the
second leading cause of loss of
biodiversity in our
environment they can change water
chemistry and water quality they can
make our water warmer by holding heat
and affecting our fisheries and overall
health of our systems they certainly
hinder recreation in our state and
impact swimming and boating and fishing
is also impacted um even though people
go after the weed beds when they're
fishing a little too much is not often
good uh also a lot of these uh
management issues lead to millions of
dollars of management costs in New
Hampshire and economic studies out of
the University of New Hampshire have
shown that aquatic invasive species can
reduce property values on lakes and
rivers by as much as 10 to 16% so that
can be a significant
impact as for the State of the State we
have uh over about a thousand lakes and
ponds and about
16,000 um miles of rivers and 11,000
miles of rivers and streams across the
state and this map shows you the
distribution of aquatic invasive species
growth and I for some reason did not
forget the top half of this map uh there
are just no invasives that we've
documented in the northern part of our
state most of them are isolated to the
southern half and that is is mostly
aquatic invasive plants that you're
seeing there 97 of those water bodies
that I mentioned the count of are
infested 11 river systems and 86 leaks
and ponds in fact most of you represent
a district or are near a district that
have some type of invasive species
growth so it is definitely far-reaching
and we have a total of 133 infestations
what that means is some water bodies
have more than one thing the Nasha River
in nashwa has has six different invasive
species so doesn't the Connecticut River
in multiple Parts uh many of our Lakes
have a few different things including
our state's largest lake lake winaki
with three different invasive species so
it is it is a very felt problem across
the state and I just wanted to because
photos show a lot this was water
chestnut on the nashal river this was
about an 8 acre patch we've since
remediated it so it doesn't look like
this anymore but this was pretty
devastating to the nashille river
uh this is the pem jaset river in
Bristol and that is all variable mil
foil choking a stretch of the river
system near the boat
launch that is uh Le pond in molten Boro
with variable mil
foil that's fan wart from Robinson Pond
and Hudson with dense
growth and this is a new invasive
species that we have up in Lake wiip
pasak that I documented in 2020 it is
the only public water body across the
country that has this plant and we had
to do a lot of research to figure it out
and it is spreading wild uh widely in
Lake winaki at this point and of course
that's posing a threat to opii
winnisquam the wabaki river the pemi the
miramac river all the way through the
system so you can see how flow through
is significant it moves with
water and then of course we have animals
uh New Hampshire has uh several aquatic
invasive animals that we watch these
actually fall under the jurisdiction of
the fishing game department but we keep
eyes on them because we are out on these
water bodies looking for them the top
left spiny water flea was recently
documented in Lake winaki two years ago
and we've already seen some significant
changes to the health of Winnie because
of that that organism in the leak and uh
a couple of the others the Chinese
mystery snail and Asian clam we don't
have we do have in New Hampshire the
zebra muscle we don't yet uh the Asian
clam is in several water bodies from bow
South through the southern border and
then Chinese mystery snail is in dozens
of water bodies causing impacts to food
webs and um Aesthetics
mainly so what we do and this is sort of
a Continuum or a progression I guess
more we try our best to prevent new
infestations as much as possible and
this is most cost effective we do a lot
of Outreach and education signage
we have laws and rules that prohibit the
sale transport introduction of aquatic
invasive species so that we can prevent
them from coming to New Hampshire and
spreading within New Hampshire when they
get here we also focus a lot on early
detection we have volunteer networks
that do monitoring we also have
biologists that go out and do surveys
and we try to find species early before
they spread quickly so that we can
manage them effectively and hope for
eradication rapid response is something
that we do when we find something it's
that quick response to get out there and
and remove it as quickly as possible and
then if we don't get ahead of it or an
infestation is Advanced before we get to
it long-term management is where we are
and that is a zone that we often don't
get out of or we can never get out of
and that's where the bulk of the money
comes from for millions of dollars a
year of management so that is the
progression that we typically see we do
have funding that provides support to
municipalities and associations across
the state we will pay for 100% of a new
infestation in a water body with State
funding we are funded from boat
registration fees a $99.50 fee per boat
registration that gives us about
$850,000 a year to work with for our
budget and you can probably do the math
and figure out that if we have million
dollars of cost that money does not just
come from us we have to have match
programs with other entities and
municipalities and other groups provide
that match to do the implementation uh
work so a lot of them do warrant
articles and capital uh allocations in
light on of budgeting to help support
those costs so uh it is a big problem
Statewide and that uh is something that
we continue to work on so that is the
overview of Aquatic invasives and I'm
happy to answer questions with my
colleagues or on this specifically thank
you so very much uh representative comto
thank thank you madam chair um and thank
you for your presentation is it possible
for you to send that presentation to the
committee of course I'll email it to the
group yes thank you thank you
absolutely y um you're
next huh yeah sure uh questions for Amy
or for solid waste great uh thank you
very much for sharing about the appears
like quite a robust program on household
hazardous waste that we have in New
Hampshire which is great um my question
is how are we doing in New Hampshire uh
on the other side of the solid waste
issue which is reduction recycling reuse
rather than just burial and landfills or
incineration how's that how do we
compare with our neighboring states and
and uh any suggestions what we might be
doing in the future sure thank you for
the question so yeah we reduction you
know it's baked into the statute that
reduction of waste and avoiding
generating in the first place and then
um things like composting and and
recycling our preferred methods of
managing waste and and we are working
hard to do that we for many years our
our Bureau was underresourced in terms
of have not really having the staff to
help Advance those kinds of programs in
recent years we begun to get staffed up
again and that's been really helpful
we've also had great support and and um
guidance from the legislature and from
the solid waste working group which
meets monthly to provide guidance to us
and and talk talk about um advancing
different um uh initiatives to try to
reduce waste a few years ago there was a
a bill pass to change the statutory
language regarding setting waste
disposal reduction goals for the state
and we're working hard to address those
um we have a number of programs now
where we're trying to educate uh right
at the Grassroots level making sure we
educate the public about how and where
they can recycle things we provided a
lot of new information on our website to
help educate um uh the public about how
to reduce waste and how to recycle waste
that they might generate we also are
getting more in a position now with some
limited Staffing at least to help
provide more technical assistance to
communities into towns and the training
because really the the way that waste
gets managed in New Hampshire and the
way that people learn about what they
can do to limit their waste is really
kind of a very Municipal thing most
people that live in New Hampshire if
they don't have curbside pickup or even
if they do they also have a transfer
station in their town which is a a hub
in the town where they can go and uh
have the opportunity to recycle various
materials and get and handle materials
in in ways that don't necessarily
include just ultimate Landfield disposal
so we're making progress there I think
if I was asked to compare to other
states we're probably a little behind
because many of those other states have
put a lot of resources and um have
passed laws to help help Advance some of
those restrictive uh you know uh
programs that help uh limit the amount
of waste that's disposed of in landfills
for example both Vermont and
Massachusetts have had uh Organics
waistbands that started 10 years ago and
then have advanced to a point where in
Vermont virtually all organic waste is
is is prohibited from being disposed of
in a landfill we're kind of at the baby
steps now we have that first bill which
is very similar to what Vermont passed
many years ago which says if you
generate greater than um a 100 tons of
of waste excuse me if you generate
greater than one ton of waste per week
um you you need to make sure that you
you're not allowed to to landfill that
waste if you're located near a facility
that can manage it in another way so
we're going to be implementing that
we're going to be writing rules for that
we're doing a a waste characterization
study across all types of waste right
now but also specifically looking to do
a study to understand what the organic
waste sources are in our state and how
those might be managed so that we can
Implement that wasteband in a way that
will really help um our communities to
start uh reducing the amount of organic
was that they send to a landfill that's
a lot but I appr thank you and I'd like
to uh have uh Miss magula give us um
your title what what's your title Chief
acatic biologist Chief aquatic biologist
thank you okay uh questions represent
Penza um just one thing was the
presentation you're going to be able to
send that out that was my first one and
then my second one is um
the uh Department of Agriculture had
right in like their second slide had put
um some information on the on the budget
and they had outlined um all of their
different employees and stuff like that
is that something that um New Hampshire
Dees could provide to the committee I
think it's very helpful sure you're
talking about an org chart that shows
the number of positions and positions
and and exactly and um what the budget
was for
2025 um from general fund other they
have yeah they have it all kind of be
really helpful for us as you can imagine
we're in a budget year so we're
preparing all that material and I'll
I'll look at what would be the most
helpful and we'll try to send something
along to the committee that'd be great
yeah they had broken it down by um the
fiscal year 2025 authorized how much
they were authorized how much was coming
from the general fund how much money
they were getting from other sources how
much money they were getting from the
federal government um and the total
unrestricted
revenues
followup yeah sure I'm I'm sure we can
provide that I'm sorry what' you say I
just had a followup sure go ahead
followup yes so when they had um done
that I had asked for them to give like a
comparison so they gave us 25 and just
to see okay well where were we you know
four or five years ago compared to now
so they were going to be um able to
provide us that information it would be
great just to have that perspective um
my other piece of that is if if it's
broken out specifically um besides de
DHHS Dees received um the greatest
number of arpa funds um actually uh
pretty much New Hampshire got more Dees
New Hampshire got more than any another
um Environmental Service Agency in the
country so I'd like that spelled out too
how much you guys got just in staff
alone you got it's got over $6 million
so I just like to see where all those
things are kind of at sure we we've been
doing a tremendous amount of work with
arpa funds providing assistance to
communities across the state and uh that
information is being compiled and I'm
sure I can provide something that will
help illustrate that to the committee
okay representative Bixby yes so um
getting back to the uh organic wasteband
um that so that is coming online in the
next month I believe and I was wondering
uh where do we stand in terms of uh
facilities that are able to uh take that
waste and deal with it sure well and it
it took us some time to get the position
that was created hired and on board and
they're working hard that and they've
been focusing on getting uh requests for
uh proposals out for the the Organics
waste study that we'll be conducting and
then also their priority will be getting
rules going so I think there was an
article recently in which uh um she was
uh um Jenny Mitchell is her name by the
way and she was interviewed and uh it
was a good article that sort of
explained that our initial approach to
this is going to be to really understand
what the lay of the land is what we've
got for generators out there what we
have for existing facilities or
facilities that are looking to size up
and and be and provide more Capac capity
it's really going to be educational in
the beginning because we we we need to
get the regulated Community the folks
who are going to be subject to this
understanding what the rules are going
to require and where they can go to
manage their waste in an alternative
fashion so there's going to be you know
it's not like we're going to be out
there doing inspections next month to
see who's complying we're really trying
to um get a program stood up and get
people educated as to how it's going to
work and but we're uh we're dedicated to
getting that done thank representative
Scully is next and then we'll have um
thank you madam chair thank you for
coming today to speak with us uh what is
the relationship between solid waste and
the dees because listening to you what
sounds like you're actually doing the
majority of the cleanups in New
Hampshire is that true or H how is that
distributed between the two
departments um I'm not sure I understand
your question I mean DS is the the
agency that is T it is tasked by this
the legislature in RSA 49m which is a
solid waste management act to regulate
and administer a permit system for
proper management of solid waste in the
state um are you asking compared to
another agency or I'm sorry just not
sure okay forgive me for being unclear
but it did sound like I mean you you
have the oil remediation fund you have
the MTP fund uh hazardous waste it
sounded like you were administering all
the cleanups of those sites so it seemed
like all of that work was being done
through the the Solid Waste Department
uh no actually um so the waste
management division is bigger than just
Solid Waste you know the five bureaus
that we described here today um cover we
have a very large um scope of work if it
if you will um we um have uh under
separate laws RSA 147a establishes the
Hazardous Waste requirements we're
tasked with with the waste division is
tasked with administering that um 146
RSA 146 C and D establish the oil the
the rules and the law that covers
management of oil we're tasked with that
as well in the division um and so um
while Solid Waste is a very important
part of what we do it's not the only
thing that we
do I'm not sure I got to your
answer well it just seem for my
experience I had done some hazardous way
site investigation is in cleanups what
your funding mechanisms to pay for
covered almost everything that I used to
deal with and do so it just seemed like
it was more in your purview that it was
over a Dees do you think I'm missing his
of what I was going to share is that um
much of the work that gets done
regarding hazardous waste sites and oil
sites is done by um environmental
Consultants or private contractor
scientists of some sort and um we uh
oversee their work in one fashion or
another um most often by them submitting
reports to us and US checking to make
sure that what they've done meets the
requirements does that help yes it does
thank you sure uh one more question
representative wheeler because we're
we're running a little late and um I
after your question is answered I want
to take a couple minute break and then
we can have uh our food safety division
folks come and talk thank you thank you
chair eron this should be pretty easy I
just have a question questions about the
groundwater trust fund Advisory Board
who appoints to that board is the
governor the speaker the Senate
President right so that that is actually
I think a 21 member commission and it is
uh largely appointed by the governor
there are some uh positions that stem
from the position so there's a there's
always a design from from the dees
there's a design from business and
economic Affairs um and then for there
are some legislative uh designes and
then many of the other I believe most of
the other positions are are are then
they may cover certain areas or sectors
of uh of the economy if you will people
who are you know members of the
Wastewater Treatment Community or The
Drinking Water Treatment Community but I
think most of those are nominated by the
governor quick followup quick followup
just so I have my notes fully complete
here now you said a certain percentage
of the state gets their water from Mill
and you knew from uh Wells and you knew
that off the top of your head what is
the percentage of I think the number
we're working with right now is that
about 45% of the state's population gets
its well from a private gets its
drinking water from a private drink
individual drinking water well as
opposed to being connected to either a
community water system or a large
Municipal public water system thank you
director wson you're welcome thank you
so much well I want to is it a quick
question yes okay quick I'll allow one
more that's it okay uh it's more of a
asking for information so it goes back
to the MTB remediation Bureau piece um
one of the questions he just answered in
regards with that are anybody on is on
that commission are they
paid the drinking water and groundwater
trust fund commission um no I don't
there's there's no I I believe they
might get reimbursed for mileage if they
seek it but I don't believe there's
there's no salaries or or stiens or
anything associated with that those are
volunteer positions so I used to go to
the website all the time where it had
everything outlined does is that still
there where it shows how much is left
left in the trust how the trust has been
dispersed we still do have a yes we we
absolutely maintain a website for that
and it should be up to date okay
wonderful thank you thank you thank you
so much for coming and uh all of you for
presenting and being here to answer
questions and uh we appreciate your time
I want to take uh maybe like two or
three minute break and then we can have
our food safety division folks speak to
so
e
committee members please take your
seats want to get started with our
presentation from Department of Health
and Human Services food Protection
Agency thank you so much for joining us
ladies
good afternoon please introduce
yourselves on my name thank you um
representative Aaron and committee
members for having us um right into it
okay um bear with me I am I am new to
all this um my name is Erica Davis I am
the section administrator for the food
protection section um within Public
Health at DHHS um and with me today is
Colleen Smith who many of you are
probably very familiar with um who was
the previous section administrator so
she is here to kind of um help me
through this this first process um so
again thank you for giving us the
opportunity to um speak to you today
about uh food protection um as I go
through this presentation please feel
free to stop me and ask questions as we
go um obviously we'll also um take any
questions you might have at the end okay
and so you're new to the department I am
new to this role oh okay so I have been
with food protection for about eight
years I started as an inspector um and
then I supervised the retail food
program for um just about 7 years and
when Colleen moved over to Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control um I I
replaced her as a section administrator
okay thank you you're welcome relax we
don't
bite you can tell my nerves are
breath we're
good so I'll start with food
protection's Mission um and our mission
um at Food protection is to protect the
Safety and Security of New Hampshire's
food supply um prevent foodborn illness
um and injury through inspection
Enforcement Education um by qualified
staff in collaboration with the the food
industry and I'll just take a minute
here to to state that it really is um a
partnership between our department and
the industry um to maintain food safety
we have always taken
the um stance that we want to educate
the industry before we regulate even
though we are a regulatory
Authority So within food protection we
have um four sub programs we have the um
Dairy sanitation program we have the
shellfish sanitation program beverage
program the retail food program is by
far the largest program program um
within our section um we regulate uh
roughly 4,900 facilities um we license
and inspect um these in establishments
include grocery stores schools
restaurants Mobile units um bed and
breakfast bakeries bars Lounge food
manufacturers and of course um our
non-exempt
homesteads so these facilities um
to get a license with us they are
required to have two inspections they'll
have a pre-operational inspection um and
then within um 90 days they'll have a
final inspection um when they're they're
operating and sorry I just wanted to go
back we have um about nine and a half um
full-time equivalents that um do the
program so I added a slide in here for
Homestead food operations just to give a
quick overview because I I know that um
this committee he has many um bills uh
for uh Homestead food operators um so we
have two types of Homestead food
operations we have the non-exempt the
licensed and inspect that are licensed
and inspected by
DHHS and we have the exempt um which are
not licensed or inspected
by um by our program
um these exempt Homestead operations are
limited to where they can sell their
products uh to their own home Farmstead
farmers markets and retail stores and
the food products that are allowed to be
sold um by Homestead food operators are
foods that do not require refrigeration
for safety um or non-tcs food products
non potentially hazardous
also um these include baked goods um
including breads muffins cookies
brownies uh we have candies they can do
lollipops chocolate fudge um packaged
dry products such as granola spices soup
mixes jams or jellies um acidified Foods
uh including barbecue sauces mustards or
vinegars and then as of last um session
they are now allowed to do acidified
Foods um in their home including things
like salsas um and
pickles um these Homestead food
operators um have uh limited um I'm
sorry minimal physical facilities
requirements so they are using their
residential
kitchen so a little bit about um our
inspections um we have adopted the 2017
Federal food code um by reference in our
rule
and our inspectors um licens and inspect
to to this food code um our inspectors
may have as many as six to 700
facilities in their
districts they are based um out of their
home so their district is generally
focused around um around their home base
they may travel up to an hour to an hour
and 15 minutes from their home
um uh within their District um our
facilities may be in are inspected uh
either every 12 month from 12 months to
risk and this is just a map um the
colors show the different districts of
our
inspectors and then the towns in white
um are the self- inspecting
jurisdictions who are responsible for
their own licensing inspection of um
so food protection um does not regulate
um specific um events and
establishments um food establishments
that are as I mentioned located in self-
inspecting jurisdictions we do not
license or
inspect we have um temporary food
establishments um these are associated
with fairs or festivals that are
operating less than um that are a fixed
location operating less than two weeks
we have occasional Food Service
establishments and events and these are
generally anyone operating um 4 days
within a 30day period less than four
days in a 30-day period we do not
license our inspect uh food pantries and
soup kitchens um and then Child Care
Centers youth camps and nursing homes
are um licensed and inspected by other
so there are some food products that we
do not we also do not um regulate and
these are um eggs maple syrup honey
produce and pet foods and those are all
covered by the Department of Agriculture
the only time that we are involved with
products like this is if they're um
adding to them so if they're making uh
honey with um they're they're making a
product
from with these products or they're
taking um whole produce and uh producing
salads then then they would fall into um
our regulation otherwise these are
Agriculture uh the next program I'll
talk about is our smallest program it's
our beverage and bottled water program
um we have a wide range of producers
even though it's very small um in this
program so we have um plants as big as
the Coca-Cola plant in London Derry and
we've had producers as small as um a
high school student making a case of
soda a week to sell um at a farmers's
market so this is a small program but
has a wide range of of facilities that
we
regulate and we have about 23 of these
facilities licensed that manufacturer um
in state and then we also register out
of state manufacturer so any bottled
waters bottled water or beverage coming
into the state um they register um they
register with with New Hampshire and we
currently the next program is our Dairy
sanitation program and this program is
an FDA Cooperative program so any milk
that is crossing state lines um needs to
be inspected at a specific frequency um
this FDA Cooperative program also
requires the FDA to audit our program to
make sure that we're following um the
regulations of um the
FDA um currently we have about 77 Farms
that includes goat goats cows and sheep
and we have about 49 processing um
plants
this these Dairy inspections are um
carried out by
2.75 um full-time equivalents and these
um inspectors inspect the Farms the milk
plants the milk
haulers milk Samplers um and
pasteurizers so they do equipment tests
um at these
facilities they also collect samples um
and as last year we've we collected over
12 00 Dairy samples and water samples um
that made their way through the public
health
lab uh the last program I'm going to
talk about is our shellfish program so
this is also an FDA Cooperative program
um and this regulates moleskin shellfish
um this includes oysters uh muscles and
clams so any of these products that are
going across state line are required
ired to be part of the FDA Cooperative
program and we work cooperatively with
fishing game and Dees um for these um
licensed uh firms um to ship across
state lines we currently have uh 30 fir
protection and we have a program
specialist and a part-time inspector to
program so some of the other
responsibilities that food protection um
has uh include food emergencies so these
can include anything from power outages
floods fires um foodborn illness
outbreaks and or um radiological or uh
nuclear
events so we can assist these facilities
um during these disasters
um and with the goal always being that
um we're maintaining the Safety and
Security of the food supply during these
events uh we have uh food wor illness
outbreaks we're also responsible for we
work very closely um when there is a
suspected or confirmed outbreak um with
the public health lab um and with our
food epidemiologists who um are with the
Bureau of infectious disease
control U we
can we want to make sure that if there
is any um ongoing risk to Public Health
that we've mitigated that um once we
outbreak um we also uh have a food dis
food defense specialist who works in our
office who um takes uh consumer
complaints so these can come in the form
of email or phone call um and have can
be of Sanitation issues um can be
illness complaints contamination
complaints um she logs those complaints
and we follow up um follow up on each of
these complaints and she's also
responsible for disseminating
information um regarding Rec recalls
FDA and my last slide is just a
screenshot of our website um since the
redesign a couple of years ago we've
we've really put some work and effort
into um getting resources um in
a in a way that's easy for the public to
get to um so we have put a lot of work
into putting resources um videos uh
lensing information um and links to our
website and um so this is my contact
information um again we're happy to be a
resource to this committee um and uh
we're happy happy to take any questions
you have them thank you very much
representative wheeler thank you madam
chair my question would be about the
events of an emergency and where I could
find the
information by which I could learn more
about what the department would do in
terms of keeping the supply chains
together in the event that there was
some kind of emergency that made Supply
chains stop so we do have a resource on
the website um we have a emergency
action plan booklet um that we uh have
on the website and we also disseminate
to our um facilities and that gives
outlines how we would deal with with
each of these situations thank you
representative
Barber thank you thank you so much for
all the great information you provided
I'm curious and the uh food
establishments not under the
jurisdiction of the food protection who
oversees those I see here that uh you
mentioned that occasional Food Service
establishments and events are not under
there as well as food pantry soup
kitchens nursing homes so um the
occasional Food Service the temporary
food service and the occasional um Food
Service event um they fall under the
exemption um in the statute so they uh
as long as they meet the parameters um
in the statute they're exempt from
licensing or inspection the um Child
Care Centers youth camps um and nursing
homes are regulated by um other sections
I'd ask that you speak into the
microphone
all he um they're regulated by other
departments within DHHS followup
followup
so um if they are not if they are exempt
and they're meeting a parameter who
establishes the parameters and are those
available online yeah they're they're in
the statute under the
exemptions okay representative ktoa R
Howard thank you madam chair and welcome
than to the committee uh under the dairy
sanitation program um are you now
testing for
h5n1 um in that and are you working with
the Department of Agriculture and the
state veterinarian with that yes we are
surey so so I'm sure you heard in the
media that there is h a new USDA mandate
for states to start state level testing
so right now the the state that we're at
as a the state agency and and yes we
have we're we're communicating almost
daily with Department of Agriculture
around this planning as they are the
primar liaison with the USDA so what are
we have submitted a proposal but we
haven't started that testing it it will
hopefully with after get granting USDA
approval we're hoping to start by the
beginning of February with that program
followup uh thank you for that
information uh quick follow up on that
is there going to be a way for the Farms
themselves to be able to test or is that
just going to be the state through a
state or a vet so as I understand it a
farm could can work with any farm right
now could work with the Department of
Agriculture to have their milk tested um
I don't know about the Avail
availability of private Labs at this
point in time for a farm to work
independently of the Department of
Agriculture but right now and any farm
that wanted their milk tested as a part
of voluntary surveillance program can
work with the Department of Agriculture
Dr Crawford's office to have their milk
tested thank
you uh and representative Howard you had
a question thank you madam chair um the
the areas that are self- inspected are
they sufficiently manned and and skilled
to do that or there there's no gaps in
the in the safety coverage right no as
as far as I know of they're all um they
are all staffed and have have the the
knowledge and skill to um perform
the the necessary tasks to keep food
chain safe I I have a question about the
New Hampshire beverage EMB bottled water
program agp2 100 that's the
rules um you have rules in place for
that are those those rules based in some
RSA somewhere what do you know what RSA
that goes back
143a
okay
so okay that's all I had a question any
um so yeah for uh one other question for
me
also regarding um food emergencies and
food protection roles for power outages
floods fires do you have rules that that
correspond to how you deal with those or
I mean in in in Dees I mean um DHHS
rules or is it just some protocols that
you follow yeah sure So within HP 2300
are the administrative rules there is
requirements for food establishments for
reporting eminent health hazards to us
and there's different criteria so it's a
power outage lasting greater than than
two hours it's um a fire a flood a a
contaminated water source they're
they're obligated to report those to us
and based on the situation we will work
with them um we as Erica had mentioned
earlier we do have what's called our
emergency action plan for food
establishments which is it's it's been a
long-standing guidance document that we
have we distributed hard copies but we
also have it available on our website to
give food establishments guidance on
what they do if if they're notified they
have a boil order for example at their
establishment so they don't necessarily
have to shut down but these are the
precautions that they have to to take
obviously if it's a if it's a fire
that's completely destroyed their
building that that's a different
situation they won't be able to continue
operations but we work it's basically on
a case-by casee basis if they report
this to us we work with them on how they
can mitigate any food safety risk um
they might have it might involve
disposal of food for example if it was
contaminated with flood waters um but
each situation is a little bit different
however there is that overall guidance
document on the department's
website
okay any other questions from the
committee
see none thank you very much for coming
this afternoon and kind of playing uh uh
The Last Man
Standing uh we appreciate your
time and I guess with that we are done
with our presentations for
today and I want to thank everybody on
the committee for hanging in and uh sort
of uh drinking water from a hose because
we we had so much information thrown at
us today um I will advise you all that
we will start begin having uh committee
hearings next week at 10:00 we have four
early bills that we've gotten I
identified to us as early bills so we
will begin hearings at 10 o'clock May we
know what they are Madam chair yes you
will um they are um they will yeah
representative Bixby I handed my list
into the uh into the clerk so so we have
um
HB uh 153 FN requiring two or more law
enforcement offices in each County to
receive training regarding animal
cruelty
hb21 FN prohibiting the removal of Claws
from cats hp215 FN requiring a landfill
permit applicant to sub submit a report
listing potential harms and benefits of
the project and HB 240 FN
local uh removing the penalty of
forfeiture for non-payment of dog
licenses
L was the cat one no yeah the yes the
decline of cats oh I didn't hear you
mention that oh yeah that was okay yeah
okay so uh for um Democrats on the
committee could you just come over to
this corner I wanted to just talk for
about three minutes before we take off